permettez-moi d'abord de remercier nos
trois
[Musique]
invités Dominique moisi qui vient de
nous rejoindre qui est ici ins
situ notre
cher Frédéric Ansel qui est à je ne sais
où mais qui est en en visio avec nous
et mon vieil ami
Ellie Barnavi ambassadeur ancien
ambassadeur et au combien brillant
d'Israël en France et avec lequel je
dois dire nous avons des des liens
politiques notamment sur la construction
de l'Europe extrêmement extrêmement fort
et que je remercie tout particulièrement
d'être parmi nous aujourd'hui alors mes
chers collègues
euh d'abord nous ne sommes pas assez
nombreux parce que évidemment dans cette
Assemblée nationale qui fonctionne on ne
sait pas comment euh il y a quantité de
collègues qui sont appelés euh à être en
en en en séance publ et qui la le fait
d'être en séance publique c'est la seule
manière la manière la plus efficace pour
un parlementaire d'être totalement
inutile euh puisque seulement dans
chaque groupe trois quatre d'entre eux
euh euh exercent les les fonctions qui
sont les leurs de porte-parole de leur
groupe dans les débats qui sont en cause
mais il faut être là pour voter et donc
on a du mal dans les commissions à
réunir les collègues qu'il faudrait mais
la question n'est pas là la question
c'est que nous avons improvisé cette
réunion pour des raisons que
évidemment nous aurions souhaité ne pas
avoir à
connaître ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers jours sur le territoire
israélien a été pour chacun d'entre nous
queles que soi ses opinions
une profonde profonde douleur et une
profonde tristesse et je tiens à
exprimer solennellement comme nous
l'avons fait hier nous avons observé une
minute de silence en recevant Catherine
Colonna hier je tiens à exprimer ma
profonde solidarité et je crois celle de
la très très grande majorité de nos
collègues sinon la totalité de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'Assemblée nationale notre profonde
solidarité pour le peuple israélien pour
ses souffrances pour le sentiment qu'il
ressent à juste titre d'une
précarité retrouvée si je puis dire dans
la la la menace qui
l'affecte constamment de génération en
génération il y a là quelque chose que
nous don nous devons mesurer la gravité
cela dit euh euh il y a eu et il y a
toujours le moment de l'émotion le
moment de la dénonciation de l'horreur
le moment de la
dénonciation de ce qui c'est du
fanatisme de la violence de la brutalité
de des crimes enlever des femmes des
enfants des vieillards les incarcérés
les humiliés tués de façon indistincte
des civil tout cela c'est ce que nous ne
voulions plus revoir et c'est ce que
nous avons revu ces derniers jours et je
tiens à exprimer notamment puisque notre
ami Ellie Barnavi est actuellement à
téaviv je tiens à exprimer à travers lui
notre profonde solidarité dans les
épreuves qui affectent le peuple
israélien cela
dit nous sommes aussi une commission des
affaires étrangères nous sommes donc là
pour
réfléchir réfléchir à ce qui s'est passé
complexité
de la situation
réfléchir à ce que nous devons faire
perplexité des
orientations nous avons donc considéré
c'était une demande du bureau que nous
devions nous réunir au moment où se
passent des choses importantes et je
dois dire que là nous avons été servis
en matière de choses importantes et donc
nous nous réunissons pour essayer de
réfléchir de comprendre d'analyser et on
n est pas encore au stade des
propositions mais en tout
cas d'apprécier la la façon dont nous
devons nous orienter dans les semaines
et les mois qui viennent alors nous le
faisons nous avons demandé à trois
personnalités qui sont remarquables à
divers
titres de s'associer à nous pour mener
cette réflexion
d'abord monsieur Ansel que nous avons
célébré récemment nous avons donné
récemment le prix géopolitique avec avec
jean-lve ledrillon et le et qui a qui
est un analyste absolument confirmé des
problèmes stratégiques et militaires en
cours je le remercie je te remercie
d'être là et je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses à à dire à éclairer sur les
enjeux stratégiques et militaires de
l'affaire nous avons également mon vieil
ami Dominique les sens du TER dans tous
les sens du terme nous avons nous avons
fait de grandes choses ou de petites
choses ensemble à plusieurs reprises
Dominique moisi qui est je crois de
façon absolument évidente l'un des
spécialistes les plus les
plus les plus respectés à la fois par
l'acuité de son jugement par l'équilibre
de ses prises de position par le souci
qu'il a de dire de de coller aussi près
que possible à la vérité à la justesse
et à la justice des des des des
situations et l'un et l'autre vont
parler mais je voudrais quand même
saluer tout particulièrement
Ellie Barnavi Ellie Barnavi a été je
l'ai connu à ce moment-là a été ambass
adeur d'Israël à
Paris il a ensuite suivi avec une
attention particulière à la fois
l'évolution politique en France
l'évolution politique européenne car il
est très attentif et il faut le dire je
crois très favorable à la construction
européenne c'est un un sujet c'est un
domaine que nous avons en commun il
notamment dirigé un formidable
dictionnaire sur les affaires
européennes et il est aujour aujourd'hui
en en Israël et je dois dire cher
ami que nous avons lu votre témoignage
votre chronique dans le monde avec une
immense
admiration admiration parce que d'abord
compassion parce que nous sommes
évidemment comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure totalement solidaires des
souffrance du peuple
israélien et en même
temps à admiration pour la prise de
distance intellectuelle que vous avez au
cœur de l'événement le plus dramatique
su donner à ces événements et votre
analyse la la complexité la perplexité
la vous avez analysé globalement cette
situation comme la conjonction d'un
terrorisme fanatique qui est celui de
ramass et d'une politique israélienne
que je ne qualifierai pas je vous
laisserai la a qualifié mais qui n'était
effectivement euh pas satisfaisante nous
avions ressenti les uns et les autres
dans cette commission et ailleurs toutes
les limites de la politique du premier
ministre netanahou que ce soit en
politique intérieure ou en politique
extérieure nous en
politique communautaire vis-à-vis de la
sjordanie et vis-à-vis du ramas nous
avions euh dit dans dans un débat public
les uns et les autres à quel point
l'abandon du processus de paix
l'exaltation
l'exploitation des difficultés des
contradictions entre le ramass
l'Autorité palestrienne palestinienne la
l'indifférence aux enjeux de la
sjordanie tout ça conduisait à une
solution où certes les deux états
n'étaient plus une alternative puisque
personne n'en voulait plus mais une
alternative qui n'avait jamais été
remplacée par rien et qui enfermait les
Palestiniens dans une situation de très
grande difficulté une absence totale
d'avenir collectif ça vous l'avez dit
euh nous l'avons ressenti et nous voyons
que ce qui n'excuse en rien en rien euh
les le le ramasse pour la brutalité la
violence les crimes je crois je ne sais
pas s'il s'agit de CRIM de guerre de
CRIM contre l'humanité mais ce sont des
violences insoutenables et inadmissibles
tout ça n'est pas excusé tout ça n'est
pas justifié mais en revanche nous
sentons bien que il y avait une impasse
et que cet impasse d'une façon ou d'une
autre conduisait à une situation très
difficile alors vous l'avez dit vous
avez été le premier le seul et vous
l'avez dit en tant que qu'israélien et
ça je crois que nous en sommes nous vous
en sommes extrêmement reconnaissants
alors chacun de nos trois invités vont
s'exprimer euh ensuite les représentants
des groupes parlementaires vont
effectivement intervenir et vous poser
en en en 2 minutes et demi on leur
laisse pas beaucoup de temps il faut
dire des questions auquelles vous
répondraz de façon rapide également mais
pour l'instant nous vous nous vous
donnons la parole et je pense que vous
cher ell Barnavi qui êtes à téaviv au
cœur du
drame c'est à vous qu'il faut par vous
qu'il faut commencer et c'est vous que
nous allons que nous allons écouter avec
attention respect et j'espère
euh un peu d'optimisme pour l'avenir ce
qui n'est pas
garanti cher ambassadeur c'est à vous
merci monsieur le Président laissez-moi
à mon à mon tour vous vous remercier de
vos vos bonnes paroles et vous dire tout
l'amitié et et le respect que j'ai que
j'ai pour vous à la fois en tant
qu'intellectuel et que qu' politique je
vous do aussi des excuses je me préveau
de mes du lieu où je me trouve et de
l'état de guerre pour me présenter
devant vous sans cravate je m'aperçois
que tout le monde est parfaitement
parfaitement
cravaté monsieur hsel n'a pas de cravate
non plus il le
signale les universitaires jamais lui
lui céit c'est pas
pareil alors euh écoutez je je suis
vraiment très heureux de cette de cette
opportunité ce n'est pas la première
fois que je me livre à cet exercice
devant la commission étrangère des
Affaires étrangères de l'Assemblée
nationale mais le moment est
particulièrement lourd et je voudrais en
profiter pour vous parler politique et
pour vous
dire très clairement ce que ce que je
voudrais ce que j'attends de la France
de l'Europe
euh et euh et je vais je vais être aussi
aussi bref que je que je le pourrais
alors c'est ce qui c'est ce qui vient de
se passer qui ce qui est en train de se
passer sous nos yeux et l'effondrement
d'une d'une politique d'une stratégie
d'une illusion
euh et il faut chaque toute réflexion
politique de partir de là je sais pas si
vous entendez le boom il y a il y a
juste eu un boom là ça doit être une
interception d'un euh de
missile alors
euh l'illusion
vous la vous la connaissez l'idée que
l'on pouvait faire que l'on pouvait
balayer le problème palestinien sur le
tapis que l'on pouvait faire euh la paix
avec les étatsunit euh qui censé qu'ils
étaient de de ne plus considérer point
palestinien comme quelque chose qui les
concernit particulièrement ça donnit les
accords d'Abraham les négociation avec
l'Arabie Saoudie et que donc le problème
palestinien il existait là quelque part
il était il était gérable il était
géable si j'ose dire et que l'on pouvait
on pouvait passer outre et c'est cette
illusion que nous qui vient de nous
éclater la figure le problème palestinen
était toujours là et on comprend
pourquoi il y a dans les entre entre la
bande de Gaza et la sjordanie il y a un
peuple de quelques 5 millions euh d'ames
et qui demande que que que son sort soit
soit réglé d'une manière qui lui accorde
des droit dignité euh et et le reste
alors on nous dit que le que la la
solution de état n'est plus n'est plus
réaliste euh plus d'une fois je me suis
heuré au sourire un peu àitoyer de de
tel ou tel expert de tel ou tel
diplomate et bon ça tout cela de
l'illusion ça n'existe plus euh il faut
passer à autre chose mais personne ne
nous dit jamais à quoi il faut passer et
si si la solution à deux états n'est
plus n'est plus valable il faudra bien
la remplacer par quelque chose étant
donné que le statut quoi comme on vient
encore de le voir n'est pas n'est pas
tenable alors quoi eu un État unitaire
un État binational euh tout cela est est
absurde vous savez un état un état
bational dans la dans la dans la la
situation qui est la NRE euh ça ne peut
mener qu'à qu'à la guerre civil ou à
l'apartide ou au deux euh moi je ne
connais pas d'exemple d'État d'État
binational heureux certainement pas dans
notre dans notre région il faut donc
sauver la solution à deux états euh et
c'est là que je concentrerai l'essentiel
de mon de mon propos cette tragédie que
nous sommes en train de traverser
peut-être une une une opportunité alors
j'ignore qu sont les le véritable but de
guerre de mon gouvernement
euh je pense qu'il la décision est
tombée ou est en train de tomber
d'unfinir avec le reine du Hamas dans la
bande de Gaza c'estàd de eu de de
liquider non seulement les capacités
militaires eu du Hamas mais aussi sa
structure de
pouvoir et c'est pour cela qu'on aura
très certainement une question terrestre
avec les souffrance que cela que cela
supposera alors une fois que cette tâche
sera accomplie je suppose que c'est dans
les c'est dans nos cordes nous nous
pouvons faire cela une fois que le
khamas sera éliminé il y aura évidemment
un vide un vide politique il faudra bien
remplir alors ce vided politique peut
être rempli par Israël c'est-à-dire une
nouvelle occupation de la bande de Gaza
ce qui est impensable c'est recommencer
une occupation totale d'un territoire où
sentasse plus de 2 millions dame et cela
est évidemment hors de question alors
quoi et et et c'est là que je pense
qu'il faut réfléchir deè maintenant
rapidement puissamment à euh une feuille
de route de la communauté internationale
et quand je dis communauté
internationale je pense évidemment aux
États-Unis à l'Europe aux ÉtatsUnis
euh et évidemment évidemment à
organismes financiers internationaux
éventuellement à l'ONU euh de manière à
mettre en place les conditions d'une
transition pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
ville précisément et pour que il y ait à
Gaza
euh un pouvoir sur sous tutel dans un
premier temps capable de d'amorcer la
reconstruction du territoire et une
transition politique
acceptable et je finirai par une par une
une une remarque un rappel si vous
voulez euh que nous pourrons développer
tout cela lors de la lors de la
discussion
euh jusqu'à maintenant l'Europe l'Europe
les européens mais aussi les Américains
tel ou tel État européen on servit de ce
que les amériqu appellent de de de
facilitateur pour le dialogue pour le
dialogue entre Israéliens et
Palestiniens ils ont ils ont fait un
cadre un
plus souvent agréable euh des vagues
idées et ils nous ont laissé ensuite
régler seul le problème cette méthode
cette approche a échoué c'était celle
d'Oslo euh ça na pas marché moi je ne
suis pas de ceux qui pensent que était
un échec complet mais ce n'est pas notre
sujet ce qu'il importe de comprendre
c'est qu'il il faut
impérativement que le le tien la
puissance tierce ça peut être l'Europe
je j'espère que c'est l'Europe je dirai
encore un mot là-dessus tout à l'heure
euh devient non pas
euh une puissance neutre mais qui
facilite dialogue
mais une puissance de participation
j'entends par là que il faut qu'il y ait
dans un avant un triangle israélien
palestinien et par exemple européen euh
où l'Europe s'implique au nom de ses
intérêts et de ses valeurs mais
s'implique vraiment c'estàd que la
l'idée que l'on que l'on peut laisser
les Israël et Palestiniens seul pour le
problème a fait la preuve de de sa de sa
futilité ça ne marchera pas il faut donc
qu'il y ait une espèce de de feu de
route euh où l'on où l'on euh définiss
le but et les moyens d'y arriver et qui
aussi mett en place un mécanisme
d'évaluation l'une des raisons
principales pourquoi le procus Do s
défendrait c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu ce
que les Américains appellent du
monitoring il n a pas eu deviation on a
laissé les uns et les autres faire ce
qu'ils voulaient sans jamais exiger
d'eux qu' se conformment à ce qu'ils ont
promis et qui payent lorsque ce qu'ils
ont promis n'était pas n'était pas
respecté alors on dira mais l'Europe ça
discours que j'ai souvent entendu
l'Europe mon cher Monsieur c'est
problématique il y a les Allemands qui
ont les problèmes historiques qu'ils ont
il y a l'Europe de l'Est qui est qui est
complètement en du du coup et qui de
toute façon est est plutôt est plutôt
aligné sur les positions de la de la
droite israélienne euh moi je je plaide
non pas pour l'Union européenneoccurence
euh mais pour ce que j'appelais ailleurs
et ce que les Américains ont appelé dans
un autre contexte une coalition de
volontaires il faut prendre l'Europe
utile l'Europe utile c'est évidemment la
France c'est l'Allemagne qui n'est pas
si loigné que sapution française euh
c'est l'Espagne c'est la Belgique c'est
c'est sans doute aussi la grande-bretane
bien qu'elle ne soit plus de nôutre mais
peu importe sur ce sur cette affaire
elle peut être utile
constituer un groupe de travail
européen qui disent voilà ce que nous
pensons qu'il faut faire et les moyen
que nous voulons mettre en uvre pour que
cela se fasse si une
telle un tel groupe ne va pas la jour si
n'arrive pas à
mobiliser la communauté internationale
notamment les Américains qui ont inventé
cette expression magnifique
et leading from pas mener par derrière
il faut qu'il fasse même par derrière ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'il y ait
quelqu'un devant euh l'Europe est trop
timide à mon sens si euh une une telle
un tel groupe de travail ne se met pas
au travail tout de suite cette la cette
tragédie que nous vivons non seulement
Nura serv àien mais elle débouchera sur
d'autres tragédies nous nen sortirons
nous n' sortirons jamais voilà comme une
première une première salle si vous
voulez et je suis évidemment prêt à dans
écter mes amis mais ensuite à participer
au débat pour voir si si ces idées ont
ont ont ont
quelques quelques sens à vos
yeux je je vous remercie beaucoup
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je crois que cet
appel à si j'ai bien compris une sorte
de gestion par la communauté
internationale au premier rang desquels
se trouverait les les les peuples
européens les États européens décid à
faire quelque chose la gestion intern
national de de Gaza serait sans doute
quelque chose de très très positif euh
il me semble que ça
reflète une situation très précise dans
laquelle je ne vois pas actuellement le
gouvernement israélien avoir la moindre
option
euh qui lui permetteent d'avancer dans
un sens ou dans l'autre parce que la
destruction de Gaza c'est évidemment euh
totalement imagie inimaginable 2500000
personnes dans une situation de de de
précarité de famine ça n'est ça n'est
pas une option l'extension du conflit au
Liban on ne voit pas ce que ça
apporterait et et sinon des des des
ennuis que T a déjà connu l'extension à
un niveau plus élevé de de la guerre
vers l'Iran ce serait effectivement
calamiteux donc je comprends très bien
que face à cette absence option il y est
une de votre part un appel qui me paraît
très très justifié sur le plan moral et
et même politique à un engagement de la
communauté internationale voire de la
Communauté européenne ça n'est pas du
tout facile à imaginer et et à mettre en
œuvre enfin je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui a le grand mérite de nous
solliciter de solliciter notre
engagement notre sens des
responsabilités parce que il est clair
que l'Union européenne doit afficher
dans ces moments autre chose que ses
divisions ses attermoimements et ses
hésitations enfin nous
allons continuer la conversation sur ce
sujet peut-être maintenant Frédéric
Ansel pourrait-il
analyser grand spécialiste des questions
stratégiques et militaires pourrait-il
nous nous donner son analyse de la
situation militaire tel qu' la voit euh
dans l'immédiat et et dans une
perspective un peu plus lointaine et
ensuite Dominique moisi nous donnera ses
nous fera part de ses réflexions à à lui
ensuite les groupes s'exprimeront et et
et vous répondrait effectivement à au
aux sollicitations des différents
porte-paroles de nos groupes Frédéric
c'est à
vous merci merci infiniment monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup et merci pour
vos gentils mots de tout à l'heure alors
profondeur historique je pense que vous
dites cela parce que par charité parce
que je je commis une thèse de doctorat
consacré à un petit village donc
personne ne n'a jamais rien à faire ne
s'occupe pas du tout de de cela c'est
Jérusalem et et j'avais doublé la mise
avec une habilitation à diriger des
recherches sur ces sur la notion de de
nation dans le cadre du conflit
israël-palestinien et j'en profite pour
remercier aussi mon ami et quelque part
maîtrebarnavi puisqu'il fut euh membre
il fut même président de mon jury
d'habilitation à dirigé des des
recherches euh je je souhaite intervenir
en en quatre parties si vous voulez bien
monsieur le Président donc de de deux
fois de sens po quoi le le premier point
de manière extrêmement analytique euh le
le le timing le le pourquoi maintenant
euh j'ai une hypothèse qui vaut ce
qu'elle vaut elle a déjà été d'ailleurs
évoquée par un certain nombre de de
spécialistes ou d'observateurs ces
derniers jour mais je je je la crois
profondément importante et juste euh
c'est le c'est le saoudien euh voilà un
état qui fut pendant des décennies si
tenté qu'il ne le reste pas l'un des
états arabo-musulmans les plus
conservateurs le cœur de l'islam
sunnite le le gardien des lieuxin de la
MEC et Médine qui
reconnaîtrait l'État d'Israël
c'est-à-dire la légitimité d'abord de la
notion de peuple juif ce qui n'existe
absolument pas du point de vue de de
l'islam politique et de l'islam radical
et certainement pas du Hamas j'y
reviendrai dans un instant mais la
légitimité d'un état nation pour ce pour
ce peuple juif autant par la même toute
légitimité au combat du Hamas dont je
rappelle et j'y reviendrai rapidement
tout à l'heure qu'il correspond très
clairement à la branche palestinienne
des Irwan donc des Frères musulmans une
branche radicale qui bien évidemment
conteste absolument pas seulement la
politique de tel ou tel gouvernement
israélien pas seulement la création
enfin l'existence de de l'État d'Israël
mais la notion même de de de peuple juif
je pense que pour le Hamas cette
éventualité dont on s'approchait mois
après mois et semaine après semaine de
manière extrêmement claire avec des
gestes euh du du prince héritier bin
Salman euh avec des mots euh notamment
récemment tenus aux États-Unis par euh
par ce dernier toute une scénographie
euh c'était ça ça reste tout à fait
insupportable sur le plan identitaire et
stratégique pour le ramasse lié pour le
coup à l'Iran là je pense qu'on a une
une alliance de circonstances même si
bien évidemment l'Iran est est la
puissance du chiisme et je me permettrai
de rappeler mais je pense que vous savez
tous qu'au sein de la République
islamique d'Iran l'Islam sunite n'est
même pas toléré il n'est pas reconnu bon
enfin là nous sommes dans la dans la
grande géopolitique je pense que le
ramas se devait à décider en tout cas de
frapper et de frapper extrêmement fort
c'est-à-dire de modifier non pas
quantitativement pardon du terme affreux
non pas seulement techniquement euh son
offensive voyez j'emploie des termes
très analytiques àessan mais a décidé de
changer de paradigme de changer la
nature de son offensive puisque pour la
première fois il a perpétré un massacre
de masse ce qui peut d'ailleurs sans
aucun doute s'apparenter mais je
parlerai sous le contrôle des juristes
internationaux non pas du tout un crime
de guerre mais un crime contre
l'humanité pourquoi pour espérer attirer
sur la bande de Gaza une repipost là
aussi d'un autre paradigme c'est et
c'est ce qui je crois je le crains est
en train de se produire c'est-à-dire
d'attirer la foudre d'une riposte si
fulgurante que les que ces conséquences
et que les images qui naîtront et qui
naissent déjà bien évidemment des du du
malheur de la population palestinienne
dans la bande de Gaza la population
civile empêcheront interdiront à
l'Arabie Saoudite de reconnaître l'état
d'Israël et peut-être même à d'autres
États arabau musulmans de le faire et
peut-être même mieux ou pire à des états
signataires des accords d'Abraham il y a
3 ans de cela de se retirer de ces
accords pour moi ce timing là il est
fondamental dans la compréhension de ce
qui s'est passé je précise bien monsieur
le Président que c'est une simple et
modeste hypothèse le deuxème point il
est très lié au au premier euh je j'ai
toujours été favorable j'allais dire
naturellement à la solution des deux
états et je rejoins ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure du du papier
extraordinairement lucide et courageux
des libarnavis qui qui évoquait
notamment entre autres l'imbécilité
d'une d'une politique en l'occurrence
celle de Benyamin netaniaahou euh je je
il n'y a pas pas de mais je mettrai pas
de nuance j'ajoute simplement un une un
point complémentaire concernant
l'identité du du Hamas mince je le
disais c'est la branche palestinienne
radicale des Frères musulmans ce la même
qui ont abattu à noir el Sadat en 81 un
premier ministre jordanien et beaucoup
d'autres personnalités au MoyenOrient et
et et ailleurs euh dès sa création en 87
88 déjà à Gaza par le cheik Yassine qui
était un fanatique au dernier degré le
Hamas a toujours joué la politique du
pire mais pas seulement vis-à-vis
d'Israël vis-à-vis quelque part de l'OLP
et assurément de l'Autorité
palestinienne au cours des accords
d'Oslo je rappelle quand même que les
accords d'Oslo ont été conclus par un
gouvernement israélien qui je crois tout
le monde en conviendra n'était pas
d'extrême droite il s'agissait du tandem
Rabine Perez soutenu d'ailleurs par le
parti de de de gauche de la gauche
sioniste Meretz et soutenu par les les
abstentions à tout le au moins les
abstentions et parfois d'ailleurs des
votes favorables des députés arabes à la
cisset et d'autre part l'OLP de Yasser
Arafat se transformant à partir du 4 mai
94 en Autorité
palestinienne de 1993 à 1996
c'est-à-dire à la victoire et pour cause
du candidat néaniaou fin mai 96 face au
candidat Perez le Hamas non seulement à
lutter contre les accords d'Oslo au
dernier degré mais à perpétrer de
véritables crime des attentats monstres
dans les rues civiles il s'agissait pas
de base militaire déjà de Tavis de
Jérusalem et du reste de d'Israël de
manière à tenté de radicaliser choquer
l'opinion publique israélienne je parle
sous le contrôle des libernavis ca été
je crois l'une des variables
explicatives il y en a eu d'autres mais
l'une des variables explicatives de de
l'échec du de Shimon Perez en 1996
l'histoire on ne la refait pas mais Luu
sans doute était
substantiellement différente et de ce
point de vue-là j'ajoute un un point
puis je passe à mon ma troisème partie
rapidement dans la charte du ramas parce
que le ramas dispose d'une constitution
en quelque sorte euh qui n'a jamais été
amendé je le précise et qui n'a jamais
été modifié euh non pas les Israéliens
mais les Juifs sont qualifiés de singes
et de por fin de citation quant au
judaïsme je ne parle pas du sionisme
d'Israël je parle du judaïsme c'est une
religion qualifiée de frelaté si vous
voulez euh non on ne peut pas ne pas euh
enfin observer à minima euh la nature
profonde qui n'est pas politique qui est
avant tout religieuse même si le ramas
comme tout collectif tout groupe et
toute organisation et notamment
religieuse fait de la politique bien sûr
que le ramas fait de la politique et
entretient des tactiques et des
stratégies politiques mais son ADN en
quelque sorte et son objectif suprême
sont de nature religieuse et je
reprendrai le terme de de de de
fanatisme trisème point ça sera le seul
sur lequel je serai optimiste c'est
l'extension régionale dont on me parle
beaucoup enfin en tout cas au sujet de
laquelle on m'interroge beaucoup ces
derniers jours je ne crois pas à
l'extension
régionale bien évidemment je suis dans
la supputation tout à fait me tromper
mais pour pour deux raisons la première
c'est que au sein de la Ligue arabe qui
compte 21 États souverains plus
l'Autorité palestinienne donc 22 membres
pour l'instant ne comptons que les 21
états existant comme tel vous avez à peu
près 3 tiers le 1ier tiers qui est
signataire donc des accords d'Abraham et
je pense notamment à ces deux des quatre
poids lourds que sont le Maroc et les
Émirats arabes unis Bahrain et le Soudan
c'est beaucoup plus marginal et puis des
États qui sont déjà en paix avec Israël
et qui veulent le rester manifestement
c'est l'Égypte et et la Jordanie on
pourrait aussi évoquer la maurittanie de
de manière tout à fait marginale vous
avez un 2uxè euh un 2è tiers au sein de
la Ligue arabe composé d'état de ce
qu'on appelait nager le front du refus
alors qui à leurs yeux existe toujours
bon ben c'est évidemment la Syrie c'est
l'Algérie et quelques autres États de de
ce type-là et enfin le 3è tiers de de la
Ligue arabe ce sont des États qui
n'existe plus que sur le papier la
Somalie n'existe plus que sur le papier
bon et on pourra en ajouter de deux ou
trois la Libye est en guerre civile
enfin il y a pas d'état libyen
aujourd'hui et cetera euh je les États
du front du refus n'ont pas la capacité
aujourd'hui de lutter en quoi que ce
soit sérieusement contre Israël d'ouvrir
en quelque sorte un un un un front j'ai
évoqué le l'Algérie la Syrie qui était
exangue et qui ne et qui ne vit sa
souveraineté que par la volonté de de
Moscou quant aux États signataires des
accords d'Abraham je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils feront mais si j'étais souverain
chérifien du Maroc si j'étais président
parce que maintenant c'est un président
qui dirige les Émirats arabes unis je
réfléchirai à deux fois pour une raison
simple en contrepartie des accords de
d'Abraham a 3 ans j'ai respectivement
obtenu la la reconnaissance des
États-Unis d'Amérique sur la
reconnaissance de la souveraineté
marocaine sur le sacrint Sahara
occidental et puis accessoirement celle
d'Israël et de l'autre côté côté émirati
moi président émirati je me souviendrai
avoir reçu de ces mêmes États-Unis une
escadrie de chasseur bombardier F35
dernier CR je suis le le seul sauf
Israël bien évidemment seul État dans la
région à pouvoir disposer de ça et puis
par ailleurs je dispose moi émirat Arab
Unis de servicees de matériel de
renseignement et accessoirement de
touristes israéliens en très grand
nombre et en très grande qualité je ne
crois pas donc à l'extension du conflit
reste le Hizbollah le le le Hizbollah
empiriquement nous a démontré au cours
des années 2000 et 2010 euh au cours des
trois dernières guerres Israël Hamas
qu'il que son agenda était
essentiellement libanais alors certes il
obéit à T an certérant et d'une façon ou
d'une autre notamment sur le plan
technique derrière le ramas et peut-être
même très directement je ne le sais pas
derrière cette cette boucherie qui a eu
lieu le le 7 octobre et les combats qui
ont lieu maintenant mais ce qui ce qui
reste certain à mes yeux c'est que le
risbollah demeure un acteur fondamental
pour le Liban il souhaite faire du Liban
un état inféodé à théran et et à
contrôle très majoritairement et très
puissamment chiit son problème n n'est
pas réellement le la survie du Hamas et
et encore moins la bande de Gaza et
j'ajoute un point si vous permettez
lorsqu'il y a eu guerre de l'autre côté
côté nord entre Israël et le Hizbollah
en 2006 et bien à son tour le Hamas
n'avait pas riposté autrement que de
manière symbolique et rhtorique hein
comme comme c'est en train de se faire
aujourd'hui du côté du risbolla donc je
je ne suis pas certain pardon là aussi
je reprends la le le concept
fondamentalement géopolitique de mon
maître grand géographe Yv la cost celui
de représentation j'essaie de me mettre
de d'adopter pour l'analyse parce que
sinon c'est pas très ragoutûtant dans
d'adopter les représentations de gens
que j'essae dont j'essaie d'analyser le
comportement géopolitique si je suis
aujourd'hui le chef du risbollah je
réfléchis à deux fois parce que le
gouvernement israëélien se sent
tellement libre de frapper de manière
sans doute ça sera mon 4e et dernier
point rapidement de manière tellement
forte en repost à ce qui s'est produit
le 7 octobre que il aurit ou il n'aura
aucune espèce d'hésitation à euh casser
le plus possible des infrastructures et
d'éliminer le plus possible des membres
de ce même risbola don je répète qu'il
n'a que faire de de de Gaza et d' Hamas
qui par ailleurs bien évidemment est
sunite enfin dernier point là je parle
vraiment je serais très très prudent et
très court je parle sous le contrôle de
des libarnavis le le je pense que ce
gouvernement
israélien il est euh
il a il y a 3 jours j'ai j'ai employé un
terme que vous me pardonnerez je trouve
pas très approprié le c'est le le
syndrome Golda bien sûr goldam en 73 les
renseignements militaires israéliens on
l'a suffisamment dit pendant ces trois
derniers jours ad Noam ont failli m
Dayan a sûrement failli en tant que
ministre de la Défense à l'époque ok
mais là je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
grave que VAM la
pauvre écoutait les les rapports qu'on
lui donnait je crois pouvoir euh
prétendre qu'il y a eu une erreur plus
grave euh au jour aujourd'hui enfin ces
derniers jours en Israël et qui va être
don le gouvernement va être comptable
d'une façon ou d'une autre lorsqu'une
commission d'enquête se mettra en place
et les commissions d'enquête
contrairement à un pays que je ne vise
pas et bien sûr ne suivez pas mon regard
en Israël les commissions d'enquête ne
servent pas à enterrer des problèmes
mais euh très occasionnellement et même
fréquemment elles font chuter des
gouvernements y compris les plus
prestigieux euh nataniaou et son
gouvernement seront vraisembl blement
comptable d'une politique qui a échoué
soit par naïveté vis-à-vis des objectifs
des stratégies du Hamas que j'évoquais
il y a un instant naïveté étant un terme
alors interprétable de mille manièr soit
l'un étant d'ailleur pas exclusif de
l'autre soit appêché par
euh surcroix d'intérêt sécuritaire pour
des implantations pour des colonies de
peuplement en
sisjordanie puisque manifestement et en
lisant la presse israëlne comme je le
fais évidemment un rythme multi
quotidien vous vous en doutez les
plusieurs régiments avaient été rappelés
pour protéger pour la fête de simratora
la fin de de souscôte donc la fin des
fêtes de ticherie de de manière générale
des des festivités organisées dans et
autour des colonies peuplement si il
s'avérait que ce gouvernement que ce
premier ministre qui dispose
statutairement des des des de
l'essentiel comme un président de la
République en France des prérogatives en
matière de défense d'affaires étrangères
c'était fourvoyé sur l'un sur l'autre ou
sur les deux je pense qu'on
aurait on aurait face à nous une affaire
d'état une affaire d'état comme il y en
a peut-être jamais eu en Israël je suis
prudent je parle sous le contrôle
d'ellit Barnavi enfin et et je
concluraai vraiment d'une phrase la
solution à deux états moi aussi j'ai
entendu pendant des années je continue
de l'entendre ce ricanement mauvais de
ceux qui à la fin des fins considèrent
le pessimisme comme une forme de
réalisme et le réalisme comme une forme
de pessimisme l'un et l'autre étant
intrinsèquement confondu je ne suis pas
d'accord avec cela il n'y a pas
d'alternative me semble-t-il à la
solution des deux états il n'y en a pas
du tout et à ceux qui me disent oui mais
c'est trop tard c'est impossible regarde
mon cher Frédéric la carte je regardais
déjà j'étais petit à l'époque mais par
la suite je l'ai regardé la carte du
Sinai doté déjà de 8 implantation
israélienne au moment où le nationaliste
ombrageu menarem bin arrive au pouvoir
en mai 1977 1 an plus tard c'est la paix
4 ans plus tard il n'y a plus
d'implantation il n'y a plus de base
militaire dans le Sinaï et la paix de
Camp David jusqu'à aujourd'hui reste
reste certainement l'une des plus
solides et des plus pérennes de tout le
Moyen-Orient alors vous allez me dire
oui mais c'était deux états c'est plus
compliqué en
2005 regarde Frédéric la carte là
j'étais beaucoup moins petit j'étais
beaucoup plus mature comm le garçon
regarde la carte de la BAN de Gaza c'est
impossible ce fut possible sous l'égide
d'un gouvernement alors dominante
centriste enfin dont le premier ministre
n'était autre que Ariel Charon assez
rarement considéré comme une colombe je
crois Charon réussit à tordre le bras
quitte le licoude il tort le bras à au
camp nationaliste israélien il évacue en
2 semaines c'està dire moins que ce que
l'état-major avait réclamé en 2 semaines
et 100000im sans guerre des frères sans
guerre civile sans que le sang ne coup
co les 20 plus h 20 implantations et des
dures des idéologiques de la bande de
Gaza plus un certain nombre de de de de
base alors il a vous alle dire oui mais
non mais d'accord enfin c'était c'était
autre chose mais mais tout est autre
chose ch concurrence est différente des
des autres je voudrais donc je je reste
indécrottablement optimiste même si
c'est de plus en plus difficile je reste
optimiste sur la solution des deux États
à terme parce qu'on ne sait pas quelle
sera la nature d'un prochain
gouvernement israélien on ne sait pas
dans quelle mesure l'Autorité
palestinienne sous le d'un autre
président aura pris davantage de
responsabilité et de poil de la bê on ne
sait pas si les Européens ce que je
souhaite évidemment avec Ellie et je
crois la plupart d'entre nous ici auront
pris comme comme responsabilité je pense
qu'il faut que nous restions sur cette
fixé sur cette boussole la phrase de
conclusion et la suivante si l'Union
européenne ne ne se renforce pas dans sa
dimension politique euh autrement dit si
elle elle refuse d'être de jouer le rôle
d'acteur d'acteur politique au sens
global du terme au sens d'une puissance
politique avec tout ce que ça compte
d'un point de vue budgétaire stratégique
voire militaire alors elle prendra
devant l'histoire et notamment devant
l'histoire du Proche Orient l'écrasante
responsabilité d'avoir laissé à d'autres
le soin d'orienter ou d'ailleurs de se
laver les mains d'orienter le le proche
orient selon leurs valeurs les valeurs
voilà et je je conclus les valeurs de
Monsieur Trump les valeurs de Monsieur
Poutine les valeurs de monsieur
sijinping me semble-t-il ne sont pas
forcément les meilleurs pour l'instant
pour le proch je vous remercie je je
vous remercie de ce ce ce magnifique
cette magnifique analyse je crois que
sur les les trois termes que vous avez
euh les les trois parties que vous avez
évoqué un sur le le caractère
fondamentalement totalitaire et
terroriste du ramas je crois que
beaucoup ici peuvent vous suivre deux je
crois que nous
chacun a apprécié avec
optimisme mais avec votre analyse sur
relativement optimiste sur les les
extensions du conflit moi on a fait la
comparaison avec le le 11 septembre et
un de mes amis me disait ce qui la
comparaison est pertinente elle est
dramatique quand on voit à quel point
les Américains ont sur réagi et réagit
de façon totalement maladroite
totalement inopportune à à à ce qui
s'est passé et là ce qu'il faut éviter
c'est effectivement une surréaction qui
serait à la fois disproportionnée et
malintentionnée là ce que vous avez dit
me paraît quand même pour tout homme
d'État responsable comme ceux de de de
l'État d'Israël et et et les communautés
la communauté internationale il me
paraît assez raisonnable de penser que
les options d'extension du conflit ne
sont pas les bonnes et troisièmement je
crois que beaucoup ici considèrent que
effectivement tout le monde dit que la
solution des deux états appartienent au
passé mais moi je crois qu'on détruit
que ce qu'on remplace et je constate que
aucune autre solution que les deux états
n'est venu remplacer celle-ci donc ces
trois messages je crois que ça ça sera
en tout cas digne de de réflexion pour
notre commission maintenant je vais
passer la parole à Dominique moisi qui
va nous livrer son analyse qui est
toujours pertin équilibrée et
stimulante Dominique c'est à toi
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
cher
Jean-Louis bonjour Ellie bonjour
Frédéric mesdames et messieurs les
députés beaucoup de choses ont été
dites et je vais essayer de de compléter
si j'ose dire les les deux présentations
de Lie et de
Frédéric Le le thème que j'aimerais
traiter est
celui du traumatisme du passé des
avertissements du passé et des défis du
présent et du futur je crois que pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé euh la
sidération
devant des enfants
décapités des femmes violées puis
égorgées il faut sans
doute
remonter à un poème qui est constitutif
de l'État d'Israël qui s'appelait le
massacre des innocents ça a été fait
après le massacre de kishineev en
1903 et c'est une des raisons des
fondements
de l'État
d'Israël une image qui est iconique et
et qui je crois est essentielle pour la
compréhension de notre débat
c'est cet enfant
terrorisé dans le getto de
Varsovie qui ne sait
pas combien d'heures encore il a à vivre
et Israël a été créé pour cela pour
éviter que les enfants
juifs se retrouvent dans une situation
où leur vie tenait à un fil où il
pouvait tout simplement être massacré et
ce qui vient de se passer pour la
première fois depuis la création de
l'État d'Israël c'est qu'un
pogrome d'une particulière sauvagerie
s'est réalisé dans la terre
même qui était
censé éviter la répétition de ce type de
situation le mur qui a été construit
pendant des années apparaît
rétrospectivement comme une sorte de
ligne magino
tragique qui a défiguré le paysage et
qui n'a pas protégé
Israël alors ça c'est le je dirais la le
le traumatisme du
passé privilège douteux de l'âge j'avais
été invité en
1995 par Shimon perees à m'exprimer
devant la cessette et j'avais dit que le
problème des relations entre Israël et
les Palestiniens ne serait réglé que
lorsque les Israéliens transcenderaient
la Choa et quand les Palestiniens
l'intégreraiit en réalité on
est dans un
monde qui n'a vraiment pas été dans
cette direction et et je crois quand je
je je vois les les événements
aujourd'hui je je pense
euh avec beaucoup d'intensité à itsrak
Rabin j'avais le le privilège de le
rencontrer assez régulièrement lorsqu'il
était de passage à Paris au début des
années 90 et c'est l'homme qui avait dit
au moment des accord d'osel il faut
négocier la paix comme s'il n'y avait
pas de terroriste il faut lutter contre
les terroristes comme s'il n'y avait pas
de négociation de paix et est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui cette approche qui me
paraît indispensable est
encore réaliste est-ce qu'elle est
possible j'ai j'ai j'ai encore un
souvenir les négociations de l'accord
d'Oslo avait des parties secrètes euh on
négociait euh le statut des réfugiés à
Rome et le statut de Jérusalem à Paris
et j'ai participé à ces réunions j'en ai
modéré certaines et j'ai un souvenir
très fort euh des relations humaines
entre les deux participants les deux
délégations ils étaient en désaccord sur
tout toute la journée mais le matin le
soir au repas c'était des cousins ils se
prenaient dans les bras
ils
s'embrassaient ils étaient marginaux
peut-être dans leur société respective
mais ils
représentaient un idéal un moment
d'espoir que peut-être il n'est pas
possible de recréer et
aujourd'hui au-delà
de je dirais les traumatisme du
passé de ce qu'il faut éviter à tout
prix et de ce qui a raté
il y a aussi les avertissements du passé
et
là
Jean-Louis l'a évoqué la comparaison
avec le 11 septembre me paraît en
réalité très juste sauf que si vous
faites des
statistiques par rapport à la population
américaine les 3000 morts du 11
septembre c'est 44000 morts en une seule
journée en Israël le 7 octobre
44000 si j'ose dire euh potentiels ont
été tués si on compare avec le 11
septembre 3000 pour 330 millions
d'habitants 44000 pour ce sont des des
chiffres macabres mais euh qu'il faut je
crois avoir présent en tête pour
comprendre l'intensité euh du
traumatisme mais c'est plutôt l'inverse
que je voulais dire c'est-à-dire que
l'Amérique avait sousréagi avant le 11
septembre elle a surréagi après et
l'Amérique en
2001 le 10 septembre 2001 est infiniment
plus forte que ne peut l'être l'Amérique
le 7 octobre
2023 une multiplication de guerres
malheureuses aventure mal préparé mal
pensé au Moyen-Orient ont permis à la
Russie de retrouver une ambition
agressive et à la Chine
d'accélérer sa volonté de puissance donc
il y a moins d'Amérique du fait du non
pas du 11 septembre 2001 mais de la
surréaction de l'Amérique au 11
septembre 2001 et donc ça c'est un
avertissement majeur car en réalité
c'est ce que veut le ramas
entraîner Israël dans euh le chemin
suicidaire qui a été celui des
États-Unis sauf que l'Amérique peut
perdre une guerre pas Israël je je vous
rappelle euh que
euh l'ensemble du monde juif autour de
15 16 millions d'habitants
c'est l'erreur statistique dans le
calcul de la population chinoise on dit
toujours c'est plus ou moins 15 ou 16
millions c'est l'ensemble total de ce
que constitue le peuple juif à la
surface de la Terre donc il faut être
intelligent et il faut aussi être
conscient euh des erreurs massives qui
ont été commises je je fais partie de
ceux qui depuis
1973 considèrent que Israël ne pourra
pas survivre à long terme s'il n'y a pas
de solution au problème palestinien que
c'est un
objectif vital absolu et en réalité
Israël a été victime au cours des
derniers mois des dernières années d'un
mélange
d'ubris l'ubris c'était
ce mot grec qu'on
retrouve chez tudide dans la guerre du
Péloponèse luubrce était déjà présente
en
1973 au moment de la guerre du Kipour
toutes les données étaient sur la table
les Américains avaient ils avaient donné
mais on y croyait pas c'était pas
possible il n'allait pas oser il
n'allait pas être capable de traverser
le canal et là c'était une armée
régulière même chose avant le le 11
septembre même chose avant le 7 octobre
et il y a le mélange du brise d'un côté
et d'évolution
politique catastrophique au fond les
Israéliens ont donné la priorité à leur
division interne on ne songe pas à
refaire les structures d'une maison
quand le feu couve aux portes de cette
maison et c'est ce qui s'est passé le
le le contraste entre la rave partie à
quelques kilomètres de Gaza est un
résumé émotionnel de tout ce qui s'est
passé le Rave d'un côté la rage de
l'autre et le problème pour Israël me
semble-t-il c'est de combattre avec
toutes ses forces et il a des forces le
ramasse
et de revenir politiquement à l'idée que
sa priorité est de se
consacré à la recherche d'une solution
au problème palestinien je crois que
c'est ça et est-ce que c'est possible
est-ce que c'est envisageable est-ce que
c'est
émotionnellement envisageable je ne le
sais pas je n'en suis pas sûr du tout en
réalité je suis moins optimiste que
Frédéric
les états n'agissent pas nécessairement
en fonction de leur intérêt ils se
laissent entraîner par les passion le
risque euh d'un dérapage le risque que
la guerre s'étende est réel ce n'est pas
le scénario le plus probable ça n'est
pas un scénario que l'on doit
euh négliger oui cette guerre peut
s'étendre car en fait il y a des partis
qui ont profondément intérêt à ce que
une nouvelle guerre obsède le monde
occidental et détourne ses yeux de la
guerre en Ukraine il y a une alliance
objective entre la Russie et l'Iran d'un
côté les États-Unis bien entendu et
Israël de l'autre et et donc je crois
moi je vais respecter mon temps de
parole je crois que je vais m'arrêter là
en essayant donc de passer des
émotions qui sont fondamentales pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et ce qui
va se
passer aux enjeux géopolitiques cher
Jean-Louis monsieur le Président oui je
avant de donner la parole je vous
remercie je remercie tous les trois de
ces ces éclairages
absolument
fondamentaux je suis tenté avant de
laisser la parole de donner la parole au
au représentant des groupes de vous
poser à tous les trois une question à
laquelle je vous demanderai d'essayer de
répondre en une minute chacun si vous
avez quelle est c'est la question que je
me pose quotidiennement depuis samedi
dernier
euh quels sont les options possibles à
court terme parce qu'on voit bien les
les projections à long terme ce que vous
avez dit est tout à fait clair que ce
soit sur les responsabilités de l'Europe
sur l'avenir du peuple palestinien sur
tout cela sur la nécessité de de lutter
contre l'hubris des représailles et
cetera mais concrètement vous êtes
actuellement à la place du chef du
gouvernement israélien
euh quelles sont les options à très
court terme que vous avez sur la table
j'aimerais bien que chacun d'entre vous
dise en une minute s'il en a ou s'il en
a pas je je m'terrog ayant été le
dernier à parler je vais être le premier
à répondre à ta question euh je crois
que la réponse elle figure à la page 1
du livre de Henry Kissinger sur la Chine
il décrit la réunion qui a lieu en
octobre 1961
entre mautsetung et ses principaux
généraux on est à la veille d'une
nouvelle guerre entre la Chine et
l'Inde et Mao dit à ses généraux nous
allons faire exactement comme l'a fait
l'empereur
leut j'ai un peu oublié au 12e siècle au
12e siècle avant Jésus-Christ et qui
Singer est fasciné par ce qu'une
référence historique d'un tel telle
antériorité
puisse être saisis par les généraux
chinois nous allons
entrer avec toutes nos forces dans le
territoire nous allons atteindre nos
objectifs et nous allons nous retirer
immédiatement et il me semble que c'est
c'est ça le le le quels sont les
objectifs
détruire les détruire la branche armée
du ramas
euh sans
doute
détruire les les l'administration en
faisant le moins de victime civil
possible et je suis tout à fait
conscient
du côté irréaliste bien entendu de la
conjonction de ces deux objectifs mais
l'idée ils vont rentrer ils doivent
savoir tout de suite quand ils vont
sortir d'accord c'est le conseil qu'on
aurait dû donner à Hollande au Mali
oui
monsieur monsieur Ansel on va prendre
dans l'ordre inverse
Frédéric je je crains que le Hamas et
quoi qu'il arrive dorénavant est déjà
réussi au moins une chose c'est à ôter
toute alternative toute autre option à
n'importe quel gouvernement israélien je
dis n'importe quel gouvernement isralien
de manière humble puisqueencore une fois
on ne refait pas l'histoire il n'y a pas
d'échantillon alternatifs on ne sait pas
comment se serait comportter ou comment
se comporterait maintenant un autre
gouvernement de centre ou de gauche je
me permets quand même d'insister
n'importe quel gouvernement israélien
pour deux raisons je l'ai dit rapidement
la première elle sera en elle sera mise
en relief avec ce que viens de dire très
justement
Dominique moisi cette fois le ramas n'a
pas perpétré une attaque il a perpétré
un pogrome et de ce point de vue là
comme je le disais tout à l'heure on a
un changement de paradigme un changement
de nature si de nouveau entre guillemets
Guil chalif avait été capturé en vue
d'échange ne sortez pas de la question
Frédéric je vous pose la question de ce
que le gouvernement peut faire vous vous
répondez d' façon extrêmement franche et
et je crois c'est qu'il a qu'il n'a
aucune alternative
Dominique nous a expliqué qu'il en avait
une qui était
irréaliste Monsieur l'Ambassadeur face à
cette question don je je mesure très
bien le
caractère impossible mais malgré tout
cette impossibilité doit être aussi
constaté je je nous vous écoutons
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur pour savoir si
vous vous avez quelque chose une une
botte secrète non militairement c'est
clair doit il doit porter le morceau il
doit détruire le Hamas la question est
de savoir comment détruire le Hamas
politiquement c'estàdire il faut il faut
il faut je pense euh faire en sorte à ce
que demain le Hamas ne soit plus au
pouvoir à gaz et c'est pour ça que je
disais la la question c'est celle
d'après qu'est-ce qu'on fait après et
après ce gouvernement mais je dirais
même tout gouvernement en Israël et n'a
aucune chance d'avoir une une conception
claire de ce qu'il pourrait faire de ce
qu'il devrait faire politiquement et
diplomatiquement la la classe politique
israélienne est dans un désarroi complet
même si euh ce gouvernement est demain
ce qui va arriver sans doute remplacé
par le gouement de centre droit ou de ou
de centre de centre gauche il n' aura
pas les moyens tout seul de euh euh
d'imaginer de mettre au point une une
stratégie politique qui nous sort de
cela définitivement et et c'est pour ça
que je m'adressais à vous monsieur le
Président et à travers vous à la France
en Europe il faut nous y aider laisser
seul nous n'avons pas de solution il
faut nous accompagner y compris de
manière ferme parce que nous ne sommes
pas la Corée du Nord nous ne pouvons pas
vivre seul et la communauté
internationale notamment les Américains
les Européens ont les moyens de nous de
nous contraindre à voir clair et c'est
ça ce pourquoi je plaide il faut
absolument que ce territoire soit pris
en charge et qu'il ait une feuille de
route claire qui donne aussi de l'espoir
à cette à cette population la
gouvernraël seul ne pourra pas le faire
et donc vous me posez la
question qu'estce qu'il peut qu'est-ce
qu'il doit faire et qu'est-ce qu'il peut
faire ce sont de questions complètement
différentes il il est h de
qu'il puisse faire ce qu'il doit
faire très bien admirable réponse en
tout cas je tiens à vous dire que j'ai
parfaitement compris le message que vous
m'avez que vous nous avez envoyé ce qui
n'a pas beaucoup d'importance parce que
je ne dispose pas d'un pouvoir immense
mais en tout cas je suis sûr que le
Président de la République française est
totalement homme à comprendre
parfaitement ce message et à en tiré un
certain nombre de conséquences je je
pense ne pas trop m'av
en en disant cela maintenant je vous
merci oui je vous en prie Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je je m' à à venir en
novembre avec deux de mes collègues
d'une
on diplomatique et sécuritaire et je
compte voir autant de personnalités que
je pourrais pour parler dans ce sens
j'ai une chance d'être reçu par le
Président de la
République c'est un message que je
compte Marel vous savez je joue un peu
les les
je je me fatigue moi-même à m'entendre
mais mais mais on n' pas le choix il
faut absolument que la France et
l'Europe se réveille sinon nous sommes
nous sommes fichus ça c'est c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut bien comprendre
nous n'avons pas le moyens de nous
sortir seul de cette de cette situation
nous je partage je partage ce constat et
je partage l'inquiétude liée à ce
constat maintenant nous nous allons nous
allons laisser la parole au porte-parole
des groupes et le premier alors c'est
c'est un un exercice assez particulier
chacun ce que je vous demanderais c'est
quand vous posez une question vous allez
exprimer des idées mais si vous posez
une question essa bien de cibler sur
l'un des trois ou deux des trois
peut-être trois des trois mais s'il vaut
mieux pas des interlocuteurs que nous
avons nous avons peu de temps devant
nous et il faut nous aider à ce que
votre question soit ciblé sur un
interlocuteur précis pour Renaissance
c'est notre collègue Hadad Benjamin
Hadad c'est à vous merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
monsieur Ansel monsieur moisi merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui pour pour
échanger monsieur moisi vous avez fait
référence tout à l'heure au poème je
crois de de Rahim narman bialic sur le
programme de de kichineev et et et en
effet alors qu'on fait des comparaisons
historiques la guerre de Kipour le 11
septembre je crois que avec son lot de
de massacre de barbarie
terroristes de massacre d'enfants de
personnes âgées de viol c'est bien aux
images qu' pensé totalement dépassé d'un
Porom auquel nous sommes malheureusement
en train d'assister en direct sur les
réseaux sociaux venant de d'Israël et je
voudrais tout d'abord bien sûr au nom du
groupe Renaissance exprimer notre
solidarité notre soutien absolu aux
israéliens dans ce moment face au
terrorisme avoir une pensée aussi pour
les familles françaises
endeuillé trop nombreuses face à cette
tragédie et rappelez qu'Israël en tant
que démocratie a bien sûr et en vertu du
droit internationale de la charte de
l'article 51 de la Charte des Nations
Unies le droit et le devoir de défendre
ses citoyen
euh l'analyse le contexte que vous avez
tous les trois apporté aussi avec le le
président n'empêche pas la clarté morale
et la clarté morale nous impose de
nommer les choses mal nommer les choses
c'est ajouter au malheur du monde disait
Albert Camu euh nous sommes ici en face
de terrorisme islamiste euh les
terroristes du Hamas qui viennent tuer
les Israéliens le font au cri d'Allah
akbar et de mort aux Juifs alors euh
vous avez avz parlé de la nécessité
d'une d'une solution politique du
contexte géopolitique et naturellement
c'est sur ces sujets que je voudrais
vous vous interroger j'avais trois
questions monsieur président vousz
plusun 30 secondes très très rapidement
trois questions rapide sur le contexte
géopolitique vous interrogez sur le rôle
de l'Iran et derrière de la Russie qui
bien sûr a un intérêt à ce que nous
détournions les les yeux de l'agression
contre l'Ukraine deuxème question celle
de l'aide internationale à l'autorité
palestinien au Palestiniens qui a fait
débat ces derniers jours qu'en
pensez-vous est-ce que cette aide est
détourné et devrait faire l'objet d'une
révision trisème question sur l'avenir
du leadership palestinien parce que
derrière le ramas il y a aussi la
question de l'Autorité palestinienne et
d'un président vieillissant très
vieillissant Mahmoud Abbas quelle est la
la la la perspective
derrière le le ramas ou est l'autorité
palestinenne en en sjordanie voilà mes
mes trois questions je suis désolé
monsieur le Président je les ai pas
ciblé mais
nous sommes condamnés exerci je pense
que Dominique moi pourrait commencer par
répondre et si nos deux nos deux autres
invités avaient quelque chose à ajouter
il le feraiit Dominique
oui enfin sur le sur la la la la
première
question il y a quand même des intérêts
communs aujourd'hui entre l'Iran et la
Russie qui qui me paraisse évident il
s'agit
essentiellement
d'éviter que ce qu'on appelait hier un
ordre américain ne se réimpose au
MoyenOrient à l'occasion de la tragédie
qui vient d'avoir lieu donc il propose
un contre-ordre le désordre les Chinois
de leur côté disent regardez j'ai
tellement bien réussi à rapprocher euh
l'Iran et l'Arabie Saoudite ce qui dans
la réalité des faits est tout à fait
faux tout le monde a échoué c'est à moi
d'essayer de faire la paix mais c'est
une manière de dire l'heure de
l'Amérique est passée l'heure de
l'Amérique est passée c'est la Chine qui
vient l'heure de l'Amérique est passée
c'est la Russie et l'Iran qui impos la
voix du désordre au Moyen-Orient sur la
deuxième question l'aide de
l'Europe je ne crois pas
qu'il faille interrompre brutalement
l'aide de l'Union européenne aux
Palestiniens on n'ajoute
pas la douleur à la douleur qu'il soit
nécessaire de de faire en sorte que cet
argent n'arrive pas au ramass c'est
évident mais donc je suis pour la voix
médiane
je condamne les propos du commissaire
hongrois qui voulait tout arrêter je
suis plus sur l'approche de Josip Borel
que j'aurais formulé de manière un peu
plus musclée
euh sur la troisè question le leadership
palestinien
euh je vais laisser Frédéric euh et elle
euh répondre à à cette question
l'abidom Frédéric vous voulez dire un
mot vous n'êtes pas obligé c'est le
passage du relais est un peu forcé par
Dominique
oui voilà je non non je suis obligé par
par l'amitié insondable que que me fait
Dominique mi à à me lancer la patate
chaude sur l'autorité
palestinienne est en dessous de tout ça
n'explique ni n'excuse rien du tout des
de l'impéricide du gouvernement
israélien actuel j'ai fait une grande
partie de ces dernières années
l'essentiel de mes études universitaires
je le rappelais tout à l'heure
humblement sur place j'ai parlé à des
milliers je crois pouvoir l'affirmer de
Palestiniens et la quasi totalité des
gens qui m'a été donné de de rencontrer
quel que soit d'ailleurs
tendance détester l'Autorité
palestinienne détestait même à l'époque
àouamar alias Yasser Arafat et
aujourd'hui n'ont que mépris pour
Marmoud Abbas un par parce que cette
Autorité palestinienne n'a pas réussi à
leur alors c'était pas elle toute seule
de le faire mais enfin en tout cas elle
n'a pas réussi à débloquer la situation
et leur apporter politiquement un mieux
et par ailleurs elle est corrompue au
dernier degré et ça je dois dire que je
c'est extrêmement triste mais je ne suis
pas certain que nous puissions nous
autres européens il faire grand-chose
sauf peut-être à manier quand même un
peu je pense qu'il faut le faire entre
guillemets carottes et bâton sur un
certain nombre de problématiques liées à
l'argent que nous consacrons quand même
au au Palestiniens sur la Russie je
serais un tout petit peu nuancé pas d'un
point de vue moral je pense que Monsieur
Poutine mène une enfin une politique et
une stratégie y compris au prochorient
très excessivement cynique mais mais la
Russie de ce même Poutine a laissé
l'État d'Israël interdire à l'Iran de
s'installer à l'est du plateau du golam
et de s'installer durablement via des
bases militaires au sud de la Syrie
c'est intéressant parce parce que à
partir de la reculade désastreuse à mon
sens d'Obama en 2013 les Russes
s'installent à partir de 2015- 2016 et
ils auraient pu gêner davantage les
opérations israéliennes ils ne l'ont pas
fait je ne suis pas certain que d'orén
avant la politique de de Poutine ne va
pas changer mais jusqu'à préssent
l'agenda russe permettait malgré tout à
Israël au moins cela de gêner le le
partenaire iranien de la Russie et enfin
je pense que pardon juste un dernier mot
si vousz président P nous avons promis
nous avons intérêt nous autres français
et européens à soutenir assez fortement
comme nous faisons déjà un petit peu
mais à soutenir davantage encore les
États arabes sunit modéré je mets modéré
avec ous s guillemets vous en ferez ce
que vous voulez mais d'un point de vue
géopolitique il le sont j'ai nommaé le
Maroc l'Égypte et les Émirats arabes
unis face à l'Iran bien sûr je vous
remercie monsieur Barnavi vous souhaitez
ajouter quelque chose si vous ne le
faites pas je n'en mourrai pas parce que
je je tiens mon nom
prés espéit que je n'en fasse rien je
juste dire phrase parce que je suis
d'accord avec tout ce qui tout ce qui
s'est dit y compris sur les sur l'état
délabrement extrême de loalité
palestinienne cependant il faut la
remettre en sc parce que on en a pas on
n pas d'autre chose à se mettre sur la
et je pense qu'il faut la il faut la la
la remettre un peu à l'état pour qu'elle
puisse prendre la la suite de du Hamas
dans dans la bande de Gaza c'est je ne
vois pas
d'alternative je vous remercie pour le
rassemblement national c'est Madame yel
mche qui est député de la Somme qui va
s'exprimer madame la députée vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président
bonjour Monsieur l'Ambassadeur monsieur
Ansel monsieur moisi chers collègues
nous avons insist ces derniers jours à
des événements d'une extrême
gravité perpétré par un un groupement
terroriste animé par un fondamentalisme
islamiste radical ces crimes relèvent de
la pire
barbarie les faits constatés sont autant
de transgression
immorales inacceptabl et révoltant des
règles internationales précisé par les
quatre Conventions de Genève la lâcheté
qui consiste à s'en prendre à des
populations civiles innocentes à les
massacrer dans des
conditions innomables pardon àer prendre
en otage pour en user de la manière
effrayante que l'on sait cette lâcheté
ne devrait souffrir d'aucune
minimisation il est parfaitement
souhaitable qu'Israël puisse éradiquer
le
Hamas afin que cette organisation
terroriste ne puisse définitivement plus
se livrer à de tels crimes notons et
déplorons que le Hamas non seulement
s'acharne sur les populations juive
parce que juive mais qu'ils prennent
aussi en otage les populations gazaoues
contre leur Gret avec une grande
violence et avec un cynisme qui
contredit certaines de leurs
déclarations de défense des Palestiniens
le ramas ne veut pas d'une solution à
deux états le ramas veut la disparition
pure et simple de l'État d'Israël on est
loin des aspirations à la paix tes
qu'elles existent parmi les hommes de
bonne volonté de chaque communauté t
qu'elles se manifestèrent autrefois par
les accords d'Oslo par exemple en
septembre
93 plus récemment quel que soit le car
contestable de certaines dispositions
les accords d'Abraham en septembre 2020
participai d'un retour au devant de la
scène d'aspiration pacifique de part et
d'autrre nous n sommes nous n'en sommes
plus là nous nous n'en sommes plus à ce
point
hélas aujourd'hui nous constatons bien
que la situation commande de conserver
du sang frroid autant que se faire cela
passe par un soutien indéfectible à
Israël dans sa volonté de faire
disparaître le ramas tout en en
protégeant les populations de part et
d'autre au plan national le
rassemblement national ne peut
s'empêcher de rappeler qu'il faut mettre
en œuvre toutes les mesures nécessaires
pour que ce conflit ne soit pas importé
en France la protection de nos
compatriotes Juifs lutte contre
l'apologie du terrorisme islamiste et
maîtrise des flux migratoires dont la
France et les Français sont les victimes
sont des préalable indispensable pour
éviter d'accroître les tensions que
nombre d'extrémistes souhaiteraient
faire exploser sur le sol national merci
je vous remercie madame la députée
excusez-moi de de vous brusquer un peu
mais n'allons pas tenir dans les les 17h
est-ce que vous avez des les les invités
ont des observations à faire parce que
c'était plus une prise de position de de
Madame méach qu'une série de questions
qui vous est posé non
bon très bien alors maintenant la
l'oratrice suivante
et c'est la représentante de la France
insoumise madame Panau madame Panau nous
vous écoutons avec beaucoup d'intérêt
merci monsieur le Président et merci
pour l'organisation de cette table ronde
ainsi que aux intervenants je veux
évidemment dire d'abord redire au nom de
mon groupe que nos pensées vont aux
familles et aux proches des civils
israéliens et palestiniens ayant été
tués aux otages et aux portés disparu
avec une pensée particulière pour nos
compatriotes français tués ou encore
disparus la France insoumise condamne
tous les crimes de guerre ils sont
passibles je le rappelle pour mes
collègues de la Cour pénale
internationale et j'alerte les bombes
qui tombent sur Gaza ne sont pas plus
acceptables que les atrocités du Hamas
le siège total de Gaza en cours est une
violation du droit international rappelé
encore récemment par l'ONU depuis le
début du conflit les ONG réclament avec
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé un
couloir humanitaire pour appuyer la
réponse médicale et le respect du droit
international plus de 260000 personnes
ont été contraintes de fuire leur
domicile dans la B de dans la bande de
de Gaza et près d'un demi milillion de
personnes n'ont pas pu recevoir de
ration alimentair cette semaine des
frappes aériennes ont elles endommagé
les installations pour l'eau et
l'assaainissement collègu un seul
message devrait parvenir du concert des
nations en cette heure si grave comme
l'a fait le secrétaire général de l'ONU
l'Irlande la Suisse l'Espagne la Norvège
le Mexique et tant de pays il faut
appeler au cesser le feu comprenez alors
que nous sommes depuis samedi inquiets
puisque nous observons que la diplomatie
française rond avec son positionnement
historique en s'alignant de façon
unilatérale sur le gouvernement
d'extrême droite israélien pas un appel
au cesser le feu nétait dicté et le
gouvernement aura mis 5 jours à
prononcer le mot pai je le dis ici nous
devons renouer avec la tradition
diplomatique qui a existé de Charles de
Gaula Jacques Chirac une voix de la
France indépendante qui exige le cesser
le feu immédiat agit pour le couloir
humanitaire et travaille à la
construction politique de la paix alors
j'avais deux questions et une
observation pour terminer d'abord euh je
voudrais noter que les trois
intervenants euh vous êtes vous vous
êtes exprimés tous les trois en accord
avec la solution des deux états et en
disant qu'il fallait continuer à
construire cette solution pour la paix
je voudrais dire que nous partageons ces
propos et donc d'où vient ma ma première
question comment pensez-vous qu'on
puisse relancer ce processus de paix
pour aboutir à cette solution des deux
états la deuxième chose c'est quelle
mesure d'urgence préconisez-vous pour
concrétiser le cesser le feu et faire
cesser le cercle infernal de la violence
et des crimes de guerre enfin la
troisième c'est pour vous monsieur moisi
puisque vous avez parlé du défi du futur
je voudrais terminer avec les mots du
chercheur Xavier Guignard qui disait euh
le la question israélien palestinienne
participe à ces quelques poches à
l'international qui nous oblige à nous
demander quel monde on souhaite veut-on
vivre dans un monde où la loi du plus
fort domine ou dans un monde régi par un
certain nombre de valeurs où la vie
humaine et la dignité sont préservé quel
discours opposé à la la propagande de PA
de guerre pardon nous assistons à une
fuite en avant d'un discours qui oppose
le nous contre eux sans qu'on comprenne
très bien où se situe cette frontière à
l'intérieur de notre humanité oui vous
avez un peu dépassé votre temps de
parole mais c'est je comprends queoui
c'est assez
dur messieur voulez-vous répondre l'un
l'autre ou les autres ou tous à la
président de
panneau
peut-êtresurés comme Monsieur Hensel
Frédéric non non sur un point je je
pense que ce gouvernement israélien euh
ne ne n'acceptera pas de revenir sur les
rails d'un processus de négociation euh
vous apprécierez mon sens de l'alitot
mais au fond Israël étant une
authentique démocratie j'ai presque
envie de vous dire que ce sera d'une
part à une commission d'enquête liée à
cette guerre mais d'autre part et
surtout euh aux citoyens israéliens euh
de euh de remplir leurs devoirs civies
comme bon leur semble et si leur semble
bon de mettre un gouvernement qui plus
centriste voir de centre gauche
souhaiterait revenir à un processus de
paix c'est tout à fait possible et la
deuxième condition c'est les non pas
l'éradication parce que je pense qu'on
n'éradique pas un mouvement qui fait du
social du j'oserais pas dire du
spirituel mais du religieux de
l'éducatif et pas seulement du
terrorisme je pense que le Hamas ne peut
pas tant qu'il ne sera pas désarmé au
sens le plus physique trivial et
militaire du terme là non plus on on
Nura pas de possibilité de vir sur les
rails d'un processus de paix et bien
évidemment je ne voudrais pas ne pas
avoir été bien compris je suis tout à
fait Ellie Barnavi lorsqu'il dit qu'en
dépit de tous ces défauts que j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure l'autorité
palestinenne est le seul interlocuteur
légal et légitime de pour visà de la
communauté internationale pour rétablir
les conditions d'un processus de paix
avec Israël je vous remercie monsieur
Barnavi non j'ai je n' rien ajouter il
avais rien à ajouter
Dominique en toute indépendance je
voudrais défendre la position du
gouvernement français
aujourd'hui qui me paraît fidèle à ses
principes
d'hier la France en prenant les
positions qu'elle a prise ne s'est pas
aligné sur les États-Unis elle a suivi
un fil qui est celui des valeurs on ne
peut pas mettre sur le même
plan
comme vous l'avez fait les crimes de
guerre des Israéliens et des
Palestiniens on ne peut pas rester
insensible
à ce que j'appelleraai le retour de la
barbarie dans notre monde et aujourd'hui
quand des enfants sont
égorgés devant leurs parents ou avec
leurs parents
euh ça rejoint la phrase par la laquelle
vous avez terminé votre
intervention vous avez dit citant je
crois monsieur Guinard que nous
choisissions le monde dans lequel nous
allons vivre et bien le monde dans
lequel nous vivons n'est pas un monde où
les enfants ont le droit d'être égorgé
ça ne signifie pas qu'il y a une
exigence de justice cette justice elle
passe par l'existence d'un État
palestinien au côté d'un état israélien
mais l'urgence du moment au nom des
valeurs que vous mettez sur la table
c'est précisément de ne pas mettre sur
le même plan les égorgeurs et les
victimes civiles de
Gaza je crois je je je crois cher
Dominique moisi que ces propos sont très
largement peut-être pas unanimement
partagés par les membres de la
commission mais sont très très largement
partagés je crois que nous sommes tous
ici sans ible à l'intérêt à la à la
légitimité du combat des Palestiniens
pour avoir un avenir collectif qui passe
par la création d'un État qui soit le
leur et en même temps personne ici ne
peut renvoyer dos à dos les Israéliens
et les Palestiniens ici le recours au
moyens la la le recours à l'horreur crée
une situation profondément asymétrique
et nous ne pouvons pas effectivement je
crois je crois m'exprimer au nom de la
très grande majorité de cette commission
nous ne pouvons pas mettre sur le même
plan c'est C ces deux combats l'horreur
qu'on subit qu'a subi l'État israélien
est quelque chose d'absolument
inadmissible pour le reste c'est vrai
que la violence est partout la guerre
est
partout les les États sont désevants le
monde international est pas du tout ce
que nous souhaitons mais là nous avons
touch quelque chose qui dépasse
l'entendement qui dépasse
l'admissible c'est en tout cas ce que
alors maintenant après ces propos qui
ont retardé le fonctionnement de notre
le déroulement de notre réunion je la
parole est au Républicain alors je crois
que c'est Michel
qui michel Herbillon notre
vice-président qui va s'exprimer au nom
de
LR
oh pardon je vous remercie monsieur le
Président je vous remercie aussi de
votre intervention juste à l'instant
vous avez dit à juste titre que ça a
retracé la majorité de
l'opinion de cette commission je bien
Notter aussi les propos extrêmement
forts de Monsieur moisi et je me permets
de dire parce qu'on est aussi des élus
et je diraiis juste un mot à ma collègue
du valde Mar Panau que je ne doute pas
qu'elle relera ce qui a été indiqué et
par le président et par Monsieur moisi
et que pardonnez-moi chers collègues je
vous le dis cordialement mais je ne
pense pas que vous êtes la meilleure
experte pour nous donner des leçons de
gaulisme en citant le général de Gaulle
et en citant en citant Jacques Chirac
c'est tout je dis juste un point pas de
querelle franco-française mais vous vous
nous permettrez quand même de vous dire
cela cont tenu des positions qu' ont été
les vôtres sur cette affaire et je
comprends vos efforts désespérés pour
essayer de revenir sur vos déclarations
et celle de votre groupe pointe à la
ligne je vous je voudrais dire d'un mot
monsieur le Président si vous le
permettez un salut très amical à mon ami
Frédéric hell dont j'ai la chance de de
compter dans ma commune comme habitant
et que je connais de longuees date et
voilà et je voudrais dire à Monsieur
Barnavi que ça a été un très grand
ambassadeur et que j'ai aussi beaucoup
de souvenirs en tant que député merde
Maison Alfort de son action lorsqu'il
était ambassadeur d'Israël en France et
j'ai beaucoup apprécié aussi les propos
de l'ensemble des intervenants de vous
aussi cher Dominique parce que vous nous
avez aidé
à prendre en compte toutes les
dimensions à la fois historiques
philosophiques géopolitiqu de des
événements qui sont arrivés je voudrais
dire au nom du groupe les républicains
je vous prie de m'excuser monsieur le
Président je prends un peu de temps mais
la solidarité et le soutien du groupe
des
Républicains face à vis-à-vis d'isra
vis-à-vis du peuple d'Israël face à ces
actions absolument inqualifiables dont
on espérait quelle que soit la
génération auquelle nous appartenons
mais nous sommes tous de la génération
d'après la Choa et nous espérions ne
jamais revoir ces images absolument
terribles de barbarie la plus
inacceptable qui nous sont donné à voir
depuis quelques jours et je voudrais
aussi exprimer notre solidarité
vis-à-vis de toutes les VI
vis-à-vis de toutes ces familles uillé
et vis-à-vis de la communauté juif
française qui est extrêmement éprouvée
alors j'en viiens maintenant je veux pas
je veux juste poser des questions comme
vous avez invité à le faire cher
Président vous nous avez demandé quelles
options à court terme et moi je voudrais
demander à nos trois intervenants
qu'est-ce qu'on fait après quel horizon
politique queles sont les voies et
moyens d'une solution à deux états vous
avez tous les trois dit qu'il y'y avait
pas d'alternative comment on fait quel
est le rôle de l'Europe vous avez une
grande confiance dans le rôle de
l'Europe vous nous
donnez plus de confiance que certains
d'entre nous avons que peut faire
l'Europe quel quel rôle politique elle
peut jouer quel est le plan actuel du
gouvernement israélien
ou du futur gouvernement israélien
d'union nationale qu'on qu'on qu'on
évoque quelles options a le gouvernement
israélien quel avenir pour les accords
d'Abraham parce que quand même ça é un
changement géopolitique considérable
considérable que ces accords d'Abraham
et donc on se pose la question que
vont-ils devenir est-ce que il va y
avoir une suite à ces accords d'aprè et
comment et enfin et enfin quel est le
rôle de l'Iran bien il y a rien de pire
que pour un président de séance qu'un
qu'un interlocuteur qui dépasse son
temps de parole sinon celui qui pose
plein de questions qui demanderont de la
part de ceux qui répondent un temps
infini euh est-ce que vous euh le le
lequel ou lesquels d'entre vous euh si
Monsieur barnaville
allez-y
alors vous vous demandez quel quels sont
les plans du gouvernement du je national
qui se dessine mais le le le le point
unique c'est c'est la guerre il ils ont
imaginé cette formule pour la gestion du
conflit parce qu'il ne faut pas
confiance justite à l'équipe en place
aujourd'hui donc il n'y a pas de plan et
pour après non plus c'est exactement ce
que j'ai essaie de dire c'est si vous
demandez vous demandez à la droite en
général droite religieuse à la droite
multationaliste qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec ces gens-là qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec 5 millions de
Palestiniens comment vous voyez l'avenir
et je le fais je fais souvent je suppose
que Frédéric aussi il a il s'est livré à
cet
exercice ils nont pas de réponse en fait
seul qui est une réponse cohérente ce
sont les ultr religieux ce sont les
messianiques et Dieu il
pouvoir ça bon ce qu' réponse les autres
n'ont pas de réponse c'est là tout ce
qu'ils imaginent c'est la gestion de la
situation telle qu'elle
est c'est pour cela
que qu'il y a je lance cet appel cet
appel pathétique c'est pour ça que je
dis que seul nous n'y arriverons pas
c'est pour ça que je pense que
euh l'Europe doit faire le travail que
les Américains on dû faire depuis
longtemps qui n'ont pas fait et je me
suis largement expliqué là-dessus par
écrit et et et par la parole c'està dire
dessiner un cadre d'action par exemple
tenez une une nouvelle déclaration de
Venise de
1980 voilà les voilà les principes de
l'Europe voilà ce à quoi nous pensons
voilà notre feuille de route et nous
avons bien l'intention de la faire
respecter parce que il y va de nos
intérêts et de nos valeurs ça ce serait
déjà un début c'estàdire que ce qu'il
faut dire ce qu'il faut faire c'est
mettre le gouvernement israélien au pied
du mur il dire que du coup ils ne sont
plus seuls il y a d'autres acteurs des
acteurs qui ont l'intention d'être
d'être respecté alors je je sais que ce
n'est pas souvent me regarde avec des
yeux rond prendre pour un naïf mais
l'alternative c'est quoi l'alternative
c'est c'est de de sortir de ce B de sang
à Gaza comme nous y sonms entrés
évidemment avec beaucoup beaucoup plus
avec avec ramas largement affaibli
frappé meurtri mais il sera toujours là
et d'ici qu'il qu'il serfasse une santé
militaire il recommencera c'estàdire que
nous sommes dans un dans un cycle sans
fin dont on ne peut sortir que par la
diplomatie et la politique et c'est que
c'est à quoi je vous invite français
européens c'est enfin faire de la
diplomatie et de la politique ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas facile je je je le sais
je sais que le Président de la
République le ressent très
profondément je sais qu'il y a d'autres
vous avez d'autres ch à fouetter
l'Ukraine est un immense morceau mais je
ne pense pas qu'il faille diviser les a
dire c'est la le la le problème est le
même partout c'est-à-dire ce sont des
grosses violations du droit
international des grosses violations des
droits humains et que on ne peut pas
dire on va s'occuper de ce de ceci on va
laisser C de côté parce que c de côté ne
se laisse pas mettre de côté il s'impos
quand même à nous et souvent parfois il
s'impos de manière moins brutale que ce
qu'on vient de voir parfois de la
manière absolument
incroyable que à laquelle vient dans C
je vous remercie je vous remercie
Dominique très rapidement parce que nous
sommes vraiment très en
retard je crois que si on veut
relancer le couple franco-allemand si on
veut permettre à la
Grande-Bretagne lorsque le labor
reviendra au pouvoir dans quelques mois
de se rapprocher de l'Europe et bien
l'histoire du Moyen-Orient le conflit du
Moyen-Orient est un sujet parfait pour
eux ces trois pays qui pour des raisons
historique ont une responsabilité
particulière des intérêts particuliers
et bien essayons de faire progresser
l'Europe en faisant progresser la paix
demandonslui de s'intéresser tout
particulièrement au conflit du
Moyen-Orient car s'il ne rappelez-vous
la fameuse formule de Paul Féval la
gardire si tu si tu ne vas pas à la
gardire la gardre ira t toi si vous
occupez pas du Moyen-Orient le
Moyen-Orient s'occupera de vous bien et
bien écoutez sous cette rubrique du CET
Hyne au bossu nous allons demander la
donner la parole à Madame ma Gatel pour
le groupe modem et
indépendant merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et merci d'avoir si rapidement
organisé cet échange nos amis qui ont
rép avec trois intervenants d'une
immense qualité que je voudrais
remercier à la fois pour la clarté de
leurs propos qui a éclairé notre
commission et aussi pour ces quelques
raisons d'espérer que vous nous avez
donné cet après-midi midi et qui nous
font chaud au cœur puisqueaprès
leseffroid et la sidération qui nous ont
saisi samedi matin chaque jour on
découvre l'horreur de la barbarie et de
ce que ça signifie à la fois pour les
Israéliens les Palestiniens et
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale alors je voudrais redire
au nom de du de mon groupe démocrate la
la condamnation totale avec la plus
grande force de ces attaques terroristes
dont qui ont fait un nombre de victimes
qui ne cessent d'augmenter je voudrais
avoir évidemment une pensée pour les
désormais 10 ressortissants français
dont on a eu la confirmation de la mort
ainsi que pour l'ensemble des proches
les familles notamment les familles des
otages la France ne s'est pas aligné sur
le gouvernement de Benjamin netanahou la
France a simplement rappelé ce que
devait être la la réaction d'une
démocratie par rapport à
l'inhumanité parce que aucune
justification n'existe aux terroristes
alors j'avais trois question question
pour chacun de nos intervenants d'abord
son Excellence Ellie Barnavi je voulais
vous vous poser une question par rapport
à la réaction de la société israélienne
on évoquait à la
fois le gouvernement possible d'union
nationale et en même temps ce que
pourrait être une commission d'enquête
mettant en cause le gouvernement
netanahou donc comment est-ce que vous
imaginez les prochains mois sur le plan
de la politique
israélienne à destination de de de
Frédéric Ansel sur vous l'avez rappelé
le Hamas et
et le premier ennemi finalement du
peuple palestinien et donc quel quel
rôle pourrait justement jouer le peuple
palestinien alors que vous vous l'avez
rappelé l'Autorité palestinienne est
totalement décrédibilisée justement dans
la la l'extermination du du ramas et
Monsieur moisi vous évoquiez l'alliance
objective de la Russie de l'Iran et je
voulais vous interroger spécifiquement
sur le rôle des Gardiens de la
révolution en Iran je vous
remercie je vous remercie si vous voulez
nos invités répondre vraiment pas plus
d'une minute chacun parce que nous
n'arriverons pas à à boucler cette
réunion
sinon alors très très rapidement la
société israélienne était euh
extraordinaement divé
avant vu vous avez suivi les
manifestations monstres de du samedi
soir mais mais pas seulement il y avait
un
véritable état de guerre de guerre
civile latente en Israël euh des puis
les rang se sont resserrés forcément il
y a eu cette espèce d'attaque frontale
et là il y a une formidable h lande de
de cohésion nationale euh d'esprit de
d'esprit de volontariat c'est assez
c'est assez admirable alors
politiquement pour l'instance on ne peut
rien faire tant que tant que la les le
bruit de combat là on fera pas de
politique normale mais dès que dès que
ce les les les combats auront cessé on
va revenir à la politique on va
retrouver les même problème et et je
pense que la
les les affrontements politiques
j'espère que l'une des conséquence de
cette affaire c'est l'affablissement aux
yeux de l'opinion publique du camp
messianique ultranationaliste et
ultraorthodoxe et que nous allons
retrouver le chemin d'une une politique
un peu plus un peu plus censé je pense
la le les jours de cette de cement sont
comptés et on devrait avoir des des
élections si j'enc les
sondages les naliao et les siens
devraent perdre le pouvoir et nous
retrouverons ensuite une politique un
peu plus un peu plus sensé je vous
remercie c'est vrai que les élections
n'ont jamais fait peur aux Israéliens
monsieur Ansel
oui j'ai d'abord toutes mes chaleureuses
amiti bien évidemment aussi à michel
Herbillon j'ai j'ai un plan en en trois
points qui tient en une minute monsieur
le Président euh le
premier une minute ah c'est vraiment une
minute hein donc environ 20 secondes
chacun si si je comp correctementz pas
votre
temps une fois une fois le le le ramas
des armées si tenté que ce soit possible
tout faire y compris de la part des
européens y compris de la part des
Européens mettre remettre l'Autorité
palestinienne dans la band de Gaza et
l'aider politiquement financièrement et
militairement à revenir d'où elle a été
chassée je le rappelle par le Hamas par
un P dans le cadre d'un PCH en 2007 2
qu'un gouvernement israélien euh
immédiatement entame tout partie de
l'évacuation de la fameuse zone B des
accords établis dans les accords d'Oslo
la la zone B ce sont ces 260 villages
palestiniens dans lesquels les israëls
ne voudront absolument jamais retourner
trois euh se mettre autour d'une table
de négociation avec 1 an au maximum en
tant que enfin en guise de cadre
temporel sur la base d'une rectification
de frontière tout ça d'ailleurs a déjà
été négocié mais malheureusement pas
définitivement établi pour parvenir à un
une solution à deux états pourquoi un an
seulement parce que les accords d'osloo
avaient entre autres et je me tais pêché
sans doute par naïveté vis-à-vis des
extrémistes des des deux bords et avait
duré trop longtemps permettant à ces
extrémistes de de torpiller ce processus
de paix une intervention courte mais de
grandes ambitions monsieur moisi encore
plus court monsieur le Président les
Gardiens de la Révolution ils sont là
pour faire en sorte qu'aucun changement
de régime n'ait lieu ils ont la fonction
à l'intérieur cor la fonction à
l'extérieur d'un d'une bombe atomique
pour l'Iran ils sont la leçon prise de
l'effondrement du chat qui n'a pas tiré
sur la foule eux il tirent sur les
femmes ils tirent sur la foule et ils
sont ils sont là pour faire en sorte
qu'un régime toujours plus
fragilisé toujours plus impopulaire
continue de survivre à un
moment ça
disparaîtra merci maintenant pour le le
groupe socialiste c'est Monsieur Olivier
fort qui va
s'exprimer ça va marcher
oui merci monsieur le Président merci en
intervenant que je seraiis d'autant plus
court que je partage l'intégralité de ce
qu'ils ont dit depuis le début et donc
je vrais simplement relever quand même
quelques difficultés bon d'abord revenir
sur le fait que les
événements du 7 octobre ne sont pas ENF
sont inédits à la fois par leur ampleur
et par leur nature il y a des femmes des
enfants des hommes des vieillards qui
ont été assassinés massacrés parce que
juifs et donc donc effectivement on est
au-delà d'une d'un d'un de ce qu'il est
acceptable je le mets entre guillemets
dans une dans une zone de guerre on est
là dans une forme de terrorisme aveugle
qui est impardonnable et qui ne le sera
d'ailleurs pas bon ayant dit cela
j'entends bien ce qui est dit sur les
objectifs finaux que vous fixez les uns
les autres et que je partage il n'y aura
pas de paix durable sans un État
palestinien et sans garantie d'une
sécurité pour l'État d'Israël mais pour
arriver du point A au point B en réalité
il y a un point a prime qu'on ne peut
pas complètement éluder et le point à
prime il est en fait quelle solution
pour éviter une surenchère le piège
tendu par le Hamas on sait bien qu'il
est là il savait très bien quelle serait
la réaction d'Israël il y a pas besoin
d'être grand clair pour savoir que
daniaou prendrait aussitôt la décision
d'une roste brutal qui offrirait des
images d'une violence inouï et qu'il y
aurait la possibilité pour lui de
ramener vers ces thèses la rue arabe en
tout cas c'est le souhait que fonde le
Hamas qui n'a que faire des palestinien
et qui en réalité poursuit un objectif
que chacun a décrit avant moi donc
comment fait-on pour que vous avez
appelé de vos vœux le fait que la France
l'Europe interviennent comment fait-on
déjà pour que la France et l'Europe
évite cette surenchère parce qu'elle
condamne aussi à échéance brève la
réalité d'une d'une capacité à
renégocier on négocie toujours avec ses
ennemis encore faut-il avoir la capacité
à le faire et je n'imagine pas que ce
soit possible pour les Israéliens ou
pour les Palestiniens de revenir à une
table de négociation si s'en suivent des
semaines des mois des années d'une
guerre longue douloureuse qui fera
beaucoup de victimes et qui en réalité
créera en fait de l'irréconciliable donc
comment est-ce qu'on parvient dans cette
phase intermédiaire à à faire en sorte
que les choses puissent dans la phase
d'après retrouver une possibilité et
dans cette phase finale d'ailleurs vous
avez dit l'Autorité palestinienne et
l'interlocuteur ok mais enfin chacun sa
en quel état est l'autorité
palestinienne et ce que je sais aussi
c'est que de manière générale on fait
toujours la paix avec ses ennemis donc
quels sont les ennemis et quels sont
ceux avec lesquels on peut faire la paix
oui vous avez tout à fait raison sauf
que là on ne peut pas faire la paix avec
l'ennemi qui est le Hamas il faut faire
la paix avec l'adversaire qui est
l'autorité palestinienne et elle est à
inventé monsieur le Président je n'ai
pas dit qu'il fallait faire la p vous
avez pas du tout une objection que je
faisais à votre discours j'essay
seulement d'en prolonger la la logique
euh
monsieur lequel lequel Dominique tu tu
souhaiterais répondre au à Monsieur
fort répondre ça n'appelle pas
d'ailleurs de réponse
particulière un constat qui est tout à
fait je crois qu'il y a le fa légitime
je je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous euh ce qui me paraît difficile
c'est
que on ne recrée pas quelque chose qui
est mort
ou si on fait ça paraît tellement
artificiel euh il sera en respiration
assistée occidentale donc l'idée
qu'on va ressusciter l'Autorité
palestinienne me
paraît
hélas difficile je la souhaite parce que
je vois pas d'autrre alternative mais
j'ai peur que dans la réalité des faites
ce ne soit pas très réaliste et le
facteur clé me semble-t-il ça va être le
facteur temps le calendrier euh les les
les Israéliens vont continuer de
bombarder le plus longtemps possible
pour affaiblir les Palestiniens vont
faire le siège affamer la ville et
interviendront quand ils se sentiront
prêts c'est pas nécessairement dans les
jours qui viennent mais peut-être dans
les semaines qui viennent donc on a une
situation un peu comme au moyenâge où on
affamait les assiégés en attendant
qu'ils tombent d'eux-mêmes plutôt que de
partir à l'assaut et sur le plan de
l'opinion publique internationale c'est
pas facile euh les pressions euh vont
basculer elles sont pour le moment on
est dans
l'indignation par rapport à la
découverte de la barbarie euh demain euh
l'opinion publique zappe euh par essence
elle est elle est pas très sérieuse euh
elle a des émotions sélectives et
successives passant par des cycles et
par d'autres donc je crois que c'est ça
le problème le temps stratégique
d'Israël est long le temps émotionnel
d'Israël est très
court je vous remercie est-ce que vous
souhaitez monsieur Ansel Frédéric
allez-y très brièvement bien ententendu
oui très brièvement il est très juste
que qu'on fait la PEC avec ses ses
ennemis et je pense que la la condition
sinequanone du choix de de l'ennemi doit
être la
conjugaison d'une à la fois d'une straté
d'une stratégie pardon d'un objectif
commun en tout cas d'un plus petit
dénominateur commun je pense qu'avec le
khamas il n'existe pas et moins que
jamais depuis quelques jours et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me permet
d'inister je l'ai dit à mes étudiants
sciences pro quelques jours je vais je
vais insister ici
aussi marmouabbas est en soit en
lui-même un problème l'Autorité
palestinienne pas forcément on on
l'enterre mais malgré tout je constate
ces dernières années que toute moribonde
soit-elle elle tient
socio-économiquement d'une part
administrativement d'autre part et même
sécuritairement dans une certaine mesure
le le le moins mal possible il n'y a pas
rien aujourd'hui comme pouvoir dans les
zones A et B je pense par conséquent
qu'il faut la soutenir pour réinvestir
militairement et administrativement la
bande de Gaza peut-être pas avec
Monsieur Marmoud Abbas mais après tout
il n'est pas seul au monde et derrière
lui il y a des hommes qui seraient prêt
à le faire je vous remercie Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur vous souhaitez dire
quelque chose vous estimez que vos deux
collègues on ont dit ce qu'il fallait
dire bien dit ce que ce que je l'ai dire
vous savez c'est proclamer la mort de
l'Autorité palestinienne n pas grand
sens est effectivement en mauvais état
mais c'est l'autorité palestinienne
n'est pas pas un homme c'est c'est une
entité inurement reconnue et qui existe
on peut lui redonner du souffle on peut
lui donner du
pouvoir si on si on veut pendant des
années la politique d'Israël a consisté
à privilégier le Hamas et à déprimer
autant que faire se peu à humilier
l'Autorité palestinienne si cela change
l'Autorité palestinienne avec d'autres
hommes évidemment Mar d'Abas é usé c'est
la fin mais d'autres hommes peut très
bien commencer et puis de toute façon il
ne va pas connaît l'alternative
oui moi j'ai tendance sans être naïf à à
partager votre votre volonté et je
trouve que Dominique je trouve quand
même un petit peu fataliste l'idée que
cette Autorité palestinienne qui n'est
servi qui n'est porté par rien
aujourd'hui sinon par un
vieillard par de l'argent qui est
utilisé on sait pas comment et par des
élections qui ont eu lieu au début du
siècle c'est effectivement quelque chose
qui ne peut pas aller mais on peut quand
même en faire quelque chose si
effectivement on s'y met
sérieusement en créant les conditions de
de d'une d'une sélection démocratique un
peu plus réelle et cetera donc je ne dis
pas que ce soit facile mais je pense que
il y a quand même là quelque chose qu'on
devrait pouvoir exploiter enfin Monsieur
pour le groupe écologiste et apparenté
monsieur Julien
Laferrière merci Monsieur le le
Président je je précise que je je parle
en mon nom propre et non pas au nom de
du groupe écologiste et apparenté
euh je je je me souviens d'un ancien
Premier ministre j'en avais beaucoup
voulu qui avait dit expliquer c'est déjà
vouloir un peu excuser et je trouve que
St a dit ça tout expliqué rend très
indulgent j'en avais beaucoup voulu
parce que je crois que le travail de
chercheur c'est justement d'expliquer
même face à l'horreur que absolu que
nous que nous avons vécu et Monsieur
bernavi J'ai j'ai lu votre votre
interview dans dans le monde quand vous
dites c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est le
résultat c'est la conjonction d'une
organisation fanatique et d'une
politique imbessique d'Israël vous
apportez des explications comme Frédéric
Ansel apporte des explications comme
Monsieur moisi apporte des explications
et comme vos collègues chercheurs
lorsqu'il montrent que la politique à
israélienne contribue à la
radicalisation de tant de jeunes et bien
évidemment apporte des explications et
c'est évidemment essentiel moi j'avais
trois questions
très rapide parce que je crois que c'est
vous monsieur moisi vous avez dit que la
la France était fidèle en fond à à sa
politique qui a été la sienne au proche
orien et dans le conflit
israëlpalestinien mais quand même
qu'a-t-elle fait depuis depuis des
années quelle initiative a-t-elle pris à
telle prise pardon face à la
radicalisation face effectivement à une
Autorité palestinienne qui n'existe
quasiment plus et face à au renforcement
de la colonisation et au morcellement
des territoires de sisjordanie euh 2è
question
euh moi je me souviens déjà il y a 20
ans quand j'allais au s-jordanie les
Palestiniens me disaient mais notre
Autorité palestinienne elle était
tellalement corrompu je crois que c'est
vous monsieur Hel qui Avaz appelé déjà
il y a 20 ans les Palestiniens me disent
ça quand disais ça quand j'allais en
sjordanie est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il
y a une relève possible parce que vous
avez dit effectivement il faut que
l'Autorité palestinienne reprenne le
pouvoir à à Gaza est-ce qu'il y a une
relève possible au fata et donc à
l'Autorité palestinienne et puis
troisième point merci de nous avoir
redonné espoir dans la solution à deux
états parce que moi-même je commençais à
désespérer en fait et avoir été
convaincu par certaines personnes qui
avec un tel morcellement il y a plus de
possibilités et je termine pardon parce
que notre collègue Nadia essayant qui
ancienne députée palestinienne elle-même
à la tribune de l'Assemblée nationale
sous le précédent mandat avait dit moi
j'y crois plus il faut une solution avec
un éab national ou autre chose donc
merci de nous redonner espoir dans cette
solution mais mais voilà éabis national
ça va être
difficile est-ce que quelqu'un ce sont
des prises de position de Monsieur
Julien Laferrière je crois que ça
n'appelle pas de commentaire particulier
de votre parts trois
invités monsieur Barnavi oui allez-y
allez-y excusez-moi j'avais pas
observé monsieur le Président juste
juste mot je pense que vous avez raison
je pense qu'il y a il y a eu une
démission de la France une espèce de
lassitude de euh d'affaement de sa
politique au Prochant j'ai j'ai parlé
avec beaucoup de diplomates français
aucun y croit c'estàd c'est le problème
le problème est là c'est pas que la
France a changé de position la France
n'a pas changé de position c'est
toujours la même position mais a on
dirait qu'elle a renoncé à les défendre
et j'étais quand j'étais en en poste à
Paris j'étais au première loge je
raconte un peu dans les livres que j'ai
laissé derrière moi maises euh mon
expérience au kedoré à l'Élysée à euh à
l'Assemblée nationale même à matinon il
y a une espèce de oui ben vous êtes
incorrigible il n'y a rien à faire avec
vous on nous a laissé mariner c'est et
et c'est contre cette espèce de de
découragement de de démission eu que je
m'assure que je je voudrais secouer not
amis français européens pour leur dire
euh ne ne ne lâchez rien parce que parce
que lâcher ça veut dire euh ne pas ne
pas apporter de secours à des peuples en
danger et
euh là oui c'est vrai que la France
pourrait faire beaucoup de choses et et
je retiens ce que ce qu' dit un moment
Dominique il a parlé de de ce trio que
l'on pourrait l'on pourrait essayer
d'organiser n'est-ce pas la France
l'Allemagne la Grande-Bretagne c'est une
très bonne idée on pourrait ajouter
d'autres je pense à l'Espagne il y a là
le noyau d'eun coalition de volonta avec
laquelle on pourrait avec laquelle on
pourrait commencer à
T je crois que votre réponse est excuse
aussi la la question la la critique
effectivement nous avons eu le sentiment
à un moment donné nous n'avions pas les
moyens et et nous nons pas n nions pas
légitime pour intervenir dans le débat
intérieur israélien qui prenait le tour
que vous savez que vous avez dénoncé
mais effectivement la réponse en disant
il faut se mobiliser avec d'autres
d'autres forces européennes qui est
celle qu'aorté Dominique mois aussi est
certainement quelque chose sur lequel
nous devons nous engager avec beaucoup
de
résolution maintenant j'ai le dernier
intervenant au titre des non inscrits
c'est Monsieur
duponteignan Merci monsieur le Président
d'avoir organisé cette table ronde
passionnante avec trois invités je
voudrais juste dire plusieurs choses la
première bien sûr nous nous sommes
bouleversés par la barbarie de ce pogrom
organisé par le Hamas que rien ne peut
justifier
et loin d'ailleurs de servir la cause
des Palestiniens de Gaza qui sont
d'ailleurs pris en otage depuis tant
d'années les
fanatiques mettent en en péril Israël la
région et la paix dans le monde alors
Israël a raison de vouloir anéantir
cette organisation terroriste mais se
pose alors deux questions fondamentales
que je voudrais vous poser mais que vous
avez déjà aborder et on a
malheureusement pas tous la réponse je
pense comment anéantir cette
organisation armée sans aboutir un
massacre de masse dans la bande de Gaza
qui forcerait les pays arabes de la
région à rompre la politique des petits
pas du processus d'Abraham et surtout à
approfondir encore le fussé de la
jeunesse palestinienne à l'égard
d'Israël à cet égard on n' pas parlé
aujourd'hui de deux situations celle de
de l'Égypte qui est en grand
péril avec une situation économique
désastreuse et le risque que je vois
venir que si vous avez demain des
dizaines de milliers de morts dans la
bande de Gaza quelle sera la capacité
d'un régime comme l'Égypte à tenir
et celle de l'Iran aussi j'ai retrouvé
un communiqué de l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie atomique du 28 février qui
détecte en Iran des particules l'uranium
enrichi à 83,7 % c'est-à-dire juste en
dessous des 90 %. euh où en est selon
vous la situation en Iran avec le risque
d'une escalade dramatique donc la vraie
question et j'ai pas la réponse et
personne ne l'a peut-être enfin vous
vous l'avez plus que moi peut-être c'est
comment peut-on anéantir le Hamas
militaire tout en évitant un drame à
gazard la deuxième et vous en avez AB
bombment parlé je veux pas revenenir
dessus mais comment donner une
perspective d'anir aux Palestiniens et
leur éviter de n'avoir le Hamas que
comme solul défenseur et c'est là la
difficulté et à cet égard
euh je regrette que la France est été
très silencieuse par le passé je ne dis
pas que c'était facile mais avant de
compter sur l'Union européenne qui s'est
entre nous ridiculisé sur l'affaire de
du financement je souhaiterais déjà
qu'on connaisse la position de la France
et qu'elle s'exprime clairement quitte
à R difficile au départ la compréhension
mais qui est indispensable pour que
ensuite d'autres pays européens puissent
s'agréger et suivre le souhait de
Monsieur Barnavi et qui a très justement
insisté dans ses articles remarquables
je vous remercie mon cher collègue bon
si vous voulez répondre ceux qui veulent
répondre à Monsieur
Ansel oui un un mot sur l'Égypte et
c'est tout à fait
important que que ce nom soit soit
prononcé je crois qu'on en a pas encore
parlé euh voilà de très longues années
qu'on évoque un un blocus
israello-égyptien israélien pardon non
il y a un blocus israéloégyptien et
effectivement sans l'Égypte dont le
président maréchal si craint comme la
peste l'expansion effectivement de ce
conflit mais également en soit les
Frères musulmans dont dont vous savez
tous que ils sont en prison en en Égypte
il n'y aura pas de solution je pense
qu'il faut absolument mettre
effectivement l'Égypte
la boucle c'est d'autant plus important
pour pour un pays comme la France de la
mettre dans la boucle que nous avons de
de très très bons rapport avec avec
l'Égypte ainsi d'ailleurs qu'avec la
Jordanie et les Émirats arabes unis je
parle de la France donc c'est c'est rare
sont les pays en réalité à disposer de
d'atout diplomatique et militaire dans
cette région et enfin d'un
mot l'une des personnalités préféré des
Palestiniens est en prison en Israël
sans aucun doute pour de très très
justes motifs il s'appelle bargouti
alors le problème est le suivant soit on
est pragmatique soit on l' pas et moi je
suis de ceux qui considèrent que
peut-être peut-être il pourrait un jour
faire l'objet d'une expulsion par les
Israéliens et moyennant sa garantie de
lutter en faveur d'e véritable Autorité
palestinienne qui reprendrait pied à
Gaza il pourrait y avoir un début de
solution dans l'après Marcou
d'Abas très très clair très très clair
proposition
Dominique
oui pour pour
prolonger la la réponse de Frédéric sur
l'Égypte et pour revenir à à votre
question monsieur le député je crois
qu'il y a un point qui est important les
Égyptiens ne souhaitent pas non plus
aider les Israéliens c'est-à-dire que on
entend des propos très fermes tenus par
des Égyptiens consistant à dire mais
nous ne voulons pas être la solution au
problème israélien donc nous ne voulons
pas ouvrir les frontières pour
accueillir des réfugiés ils n'en veulent
pas dans un premier temps mais ils n'en
veulent pas non plus pour des raisons il
y a la peur et il y a le calcul ça fait
beaucoup alors la la la la vraie
question vous posez
euh est-ce que les
Israéliens sont implicitement en train
de dire au
palestinien nous ferons le siège de
Gaza en coupant l'au l'électricité et
cetera la
nourriture tant que vous n'aurez pas
rendu les otages vous avez pris des
civils en otage nous prenons la
population
RAM ramasse absolument en disant au
ramasse pardon tout à fait en disant on
ramasse vous avez pris des des des
citoyens en
otage le siège en tant que tel en terme
de fourniture d'eau d'électricité et
cetera
cessera du moment où ces otages seront
libérés alors il s'agit bien entendu
d'exercer une forme de chantage pour
diviser la population de Gaza de du
ramas on peut plus manger on peut plus
boire on peut plus on a plus
d'électricité il faut que vous libériez
les les Israéliens c'est une je c'est un
jeu complexe d'un cynisme dangereux
je pense quand même qu'il est dans
l'esprit des généraux israéliens qui ont
décrété le blocus de la
ville bien sû le blocus ne peut avoir
que cette signification en même temps
c'est complètement c'est un calcul
complètement fou de d'affamer 2500000
personnes pour 50 tâes ça va pas du tout
monsieur Barnavi vous voulez dire
quelque chose sur ce
plan juste que Ivan bargouti qui vient
d'être mentionné et sans doute une
partie de la solution s'il y a des
élections présidentielles euh dans les
territoires palestiniens bargouti est
sûr de devenir d'être lui président et à
ce moment-là il sera difficile de
regarder en prison on en parle beaucoup
on on en a toujours
beaucoup et là encore c'est uneion que
les que les que de l'extérieur pour
suggérer au gouvernement israélien
oui ce n'est pas la parteille mais c'est
Nelson mand est
là euh maintenant les les groupes se
sont tous exprimés j'ai encore si si
demande de parole à titre individuel
alors je j'explique ça à nos invités les
demandes de parole à titre individuel
les députés sont censés j'essaie de de
veiller mais enfin j'ai très peu de
moyens tenir dans une minute et
également les les
les ceux qui leur répondent c'est
absolument inatteignable mais je fais
mon
travail Frédéric petit il est pas
là
bon ah bon très bien tu écris
simplement madame car a demandé la
parole
bon comment non mais vous inquétez pas
vous savez
bon monsieur parqu on veut parler
d'abord parce que il était inscrit avant
madame carrois merci merci monsieur le
Président pardon merci monsieur le
Président messieurs les les intervenants
merci pour votre expertise pour vos
lumières et surtout pour vos espoirs je
souffre pour Israël je souffre pour nos
frères et nos sœurs juifs de France
attaché au seul État juif au monde quand
on voit la barbarie l'horreur absolue
qui a un visage et qui s'appelle le
Hamas nous ne pouvons que condamner
fermement sans réserve aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans la peine et nous sommes dans
l'indignation demain il faudra être dans
la réflexion et la proposition toucher à
une démocratie telle qu'Israël c'est
mettre en danger l'équilibre du monde et
laisser la place aux terroristes et aux
aux dictatures messieurs vous qui êtes
des spécialistes de la question quelles
sont selon vous les pistes qui
permettraient d'éviter à long terme un
enlisement et une aggravation du conflit
dans la région quel rôle la France
peut-être jouer vous y avez répondu et
surtout comment éviter les répercussions
au niveau national parce que ce conflit
entraîne on l'a vu ces jour-ci des actes
antisémitesquan je vais vous dire une
chose vous devriez être président parce
que vous avez poser toutes les questions
qui ont dominé ce débat et donc ça
serait une excellente conclusion mais
sous forme affirmative et pas sous forme
interrogative donc je pense que nos amis
vont pas pouvoir répondre parce que ils
se sont efforcés de le faire pendant 2h
déjà et et et avec avec succès pour leur
intelligence mais quand même avec une
certaine difficulté à surmonter les
obstaces qui sont devant nous euh vous
voulez dire quelque chose de plus non
bon je vous remercie euh monsieur
legal merci monsieur le Président merci
à nos trois interlocuteurs alors d'abord
petite précision je voudrais dire que
personne chez nous ne renvoie dos à dos
les victimes des deux du massacre du
pogrom seule chose qu'on dit c'est que
le silence régulier quasi permanent et
qui est de plus en plus
assourdissant sur ce qui se passe au
quotidien dans les territoires dans les
colonies et cetera fait
partie de l'incompréhension du fait
qu'on est incapable d'expliquer ce qui
se passe c'est ça notre position pour
être
clair très bien et je renvoie à la
notion de crime de guerre c'est Vedrine
qui l' utilisé à la télé et entre autre
parce que c'est de crime de guerre parce
que entre autre c'est une notion qui
permettrait de juger les auteurs des
actes parce que c'est reconnu en droit
international une fois qu'on a dit cela
je voudrais juste vérifier auprès de nos
deux de nos trois invités l'authenticité
de deux citations parce que je n'en
crois pas mes yeux et que je voudrais
être sûr que ce ne sont pas des
mensonges est-il vrai que ce qu'a dit à
haretz il y a quelques jours que en 2019
devant les députés du
licou euh B netaniahou a dit quiconque
veut contrecarrer l'établissement d'un
État palestinien doit renforcer le Hamas
et transférer de l'argent au Hamas cela
fait partie de notre stratégie est-ce
que cette citation est authentique ou
pas le cas échéant pouvez-vous la
contextualiser pour pas qu'on
l'interprète et est-il vrai que le
ministre d'extrême droite m'utriche a
dit il y a quelques mois l'Autorité
palestinienne est notre fardeau le Hamas
et notre
chance Thas c'est deux questions
factuelles je sais pas si vous avez vous
avez les éléments d'y répondre les
moyens d'y répondre euh et
Barnavi vous êtes en mesure de répondre
à d'apporter les les réponses aux
questions de Monsieur
legal junior SMR dit ça mais mais je
sais que netania a dit c'est que c'est
qu' a éé cité dans et il a dit à
plusieurs reprises c'est la c'était la
politique la
stratéie pendant des années se vérifie
sur le terrain personne l'a caché alors
est-ce que ce qui nous dit ça c'est bien
ça m'étnerait
pas oui
oui très bien très bien 50 % de succès
c'est pas mal pour un député euh madame
madame
Piron merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs de nous éclairer sur la
situation
israëlo-palestinière qui se concentre
toute notre attention ces derniers jours
depuis le plan de partage adopté par
l'ONU en 1947 et plus d'un quart de
siècle après les accords Oslo le conflit
israélo-palestin IEN a fait l'objet de
nombreuses tentatives de relance du
processus de paix en 20 au sein même de
la région les tensions n'ont cessé de
croître dans cette région du proche ou
Moyen-orient comportant majoritairement
des peuples arabes mais parfois divisés
entre sunnit et chit ces dernières
années le conflit israélo-arabe semblait
s'apaiser depuis la signature des
accords d'Abraham par ces accords les
représentants des Émirats arabes unis du
Bahrain du Maroc et Israël officialiser
la normalisation des liens diplomatiques
l'Arabie Saoudite étant également dans
le processus de reconnaissance d'Israël
toutefois le regain de tension
israélo-palestinienne semble
compromettre cette avancée diplomatique
majeure au sein du Moyen-Orient selon
vous monsieur hercel peut-être peut-on
craindre une remise en cause ou
abrogation de ce traité ou bien des
conflits du type printemps Arab dans les
pays du gouvernant sunnite mais avec une
population chite sont-ils à craindre je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur Ansel
oui oui rapidement je citerai Gul les
états donc des intérêts en général à
court terme et dans au sein de leur
propre frontières ou à leurs frontières
immédiates et tout à l'heure je m'étais
empressé de dire qu'au moins le Maroc et
les Émirats arabes unis me semble-t-il
c'est une hypothèse ne reviendront pas
alors il pe ils peuvent très bien
convoquer un ambassadeur et lui souffler
dans les branches mais ne reviendront
pas sur la reconnaissance de de l'État
d'Israël parce que chacun a obtenu des
avantages tout à fait substantiel et par
ailleurs aucun des deux et et de la
plupart des autres États arabes sunites
euh ne ne ne revient sur la dangerosité
des Frères musulmans et et pas seulement
d'ailleurs du du ramas et puis sur ce
qui a été dit alors juste précédemment
divisé pour mieux régner c'est l'un des
j' dire l'un des béabas malheureusement
de la géopolitique et sans doute depuis
au moins tuite que cité à juste titre
tout à l'heure Dominique moisi mais
c'est un jeu extrêmement dangereux
lorsqu'on le joue trop longtemps et avec
des adversaires qui sont en réalité des
ennemis
irréductibles merci euh rien d'autre
ajouter de la la part des des deutres
invités donc maintenant c'est à Monsieur
dumonde oui j'arrive à
lireville encore merci monsieur le
Président merci à nos trois invités pour
leur éclairage ce jour vous avez tous
les trois expliquer qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que celle des deux
états plus une solution à deux états
avec un État palestinien coupé en deux
est-elle viable historiquement les pays
coupés en deux ont surtout été des
ferments des terreau de guerre comment
est-ce qu'on peut résoudre cette
équation vous avez également évoqué le
front du refus de la Ligue arabe comment
est-ce que vous interprétez le silence
du fata l'Autorité palestinienne n-elle
pas totalement dépassée par les
événement comment dès lors imaginer
qu'elle puisse reprendre la main sur la
bande de Gaza d'autant plus si elle
arrive dans les valises de l'étranger je
vous
remercie comment c'est ce que j'exprim
oui oui je crois que c'est c'est un peu
ce qui a exprimé Dominique moisi un
instant est-ce
que Monsieur monsieur
fr oui mais simplement c'est c'est très
factuel les États-Unis d'Amérique sont
tronçonnés hein donc les les Émirats
arabes unis aussi donc et et il y a en
Afrique occidentale en Afrique centrale
occidentale une une enclave qui
s'appelle Cabinda donc non c'est pas
alors évidemment on a tous en mémoire le
le point Godwin historico géographique
du corridor de Danzig mais là je pense
qu'on n est pas et de toute façon je
n'imagine pas un seul instant l'État
d'Israël a accepté lui-même de se
subdiviser sous prétexte que la bande de
Gaza et la S Jordanie soit relié en
revanche je rappellerai pour être tout à
fait réaliste et pas nécessairement
béatement optimiste qu'en 1999 et 2000
pendant quelques mois seulement mais
quelques mois qui ont démontré que ça
pouvait empiriquement exister il y a une
route qui a été aut enfin qui a été
ouverte en quelque sorte entre Gazin et
la S Jordanie qui était d'ailleurs
fortement utilisé par le Hamas pour
faire du social et des des mariages
collectifs organisés de part et d'autrre
de ces deux tronçons d'un futur État
palestinien tout ça sous supervision
sécuritaire israélien je vais peut-être
vous surprendre il n'y a jamais eu
pendant les 6 ou 7 mois ou cette route a
fonctionné de manière on va dire
autonome elle ne tronçonnait pas l'état
d'Israël mais ét autonome il n'y a
jamais eu le moindre attentat
oui juste un point si je peux me
permettre il y a eu un moment où on
disait la solution c'est l'échange de
territoires il y a des territoires
Palestiniens mais sur lesquels des
colonies de peuplement israéliennees se
sont bâtis on ne va pas demander aux
Israéliens de se retirer ces territoires
mais on va leur rendre on va donner aux
Palestiniens d'autres territoires ça
faisait partie de la la conversation à
un moment donné vous voyez à quel point
on en est loin
aujourd'hui absolument madame madame
soud merci monsieur le
président messieurs je me permets de
reprendre les propos tenus par Monsieur
moisi sur France Info il faut condamner
sans ambigué les actes barbares qui ont
été commis et il faut prendre du recul
pour comprendre d'où vient cette
barbarie est-ce qu'elle n'est pas le
produit d'une humiliation extrême je je
souscris pleinement à vos propos
expliquer ce n'est pas excuser c'est
chercher à avancer le Hamas perdure
aussi à cause du désespoir et de
l'absence de perspective politique qui
relèvent d'une responsabilité collective
ce n'est pas faute de dire depuis
longtemps que la molaise de l'Occident
dans le soutien à la solution à deux
états est coupable notamment vis-à-vis
de la situation dramatique de Gaza que
Nicolas Sarkozi lui-même décrivait en
2009 comme la plus grande prison à ciel
ouvert du monde 70 % de la population
Gazaoui a moins de 30 ans et n'a
quasiment connu que ce blocus ne
pensez-vous pas comme Denis cifer
spécialiste du conflit
israélo-palestinien qu'il ne peut y
avoir d'extinction de ce conflit sans
une solution respectueuse des droits des
Palestiniens est-ce que quelqu'un veut
commenter les propos ou répondre au Pr
occupation madame soud bah c'est oui je
me suis exprimé là-dessus je crois avec
suffisamment de clarté puisque vous me
citez je suis d'accord avec ce que j'ai
dit oui oui oui monsieur monsieur
l'ambassadeural à
vous expliquer la ce qui s'est passéit
le 7 octobre par par le sort fait aux
Palestiniens c'est c'est justifié
l'hitlerisme par les l'iniquité de du TR
de versaill ce
sont ce sont des il faut comprendre la
nature du Hamas ça je suis bien bien
placé pour pas
tout passé ma vie à étudier la religion
radicale depuis le 7e siècle c'est un
mouvement religieux dans la dans la
l'ambition et la raison d'être c'est
c'est l'éradication d'Israël pour des
raisons religieuse t qu'on a pas compris
ça on n rien compris à ce qui se passe
évidemment il y a le problème de Gaza
mais tout ça il y est je je vous
rappelle tout de même qu'en 2005 nous
avons vidé Gaza de toute présence
israélienne rien n'empêché euh les
Gazaoui de transformer ce territoire une
espèce de de vitrine de l'État
palestinen à venir ils ont préféré tirer
des des des missiles le le le blocus de
Gaza n'est pas un caprice c'est pas de
c'est pas dû au sadisme intrinsèque des
Israéliens c'est dû au fait que d'embla
dès 2006 7 on a eu affaire à une entité
violente ennemie au port d'Israël alors
je ne dis pas que on s est bien pris
j'ai ESS j'essaie d'expliquer pourquoi
je pense qu'on s'y est mal pris enfin
l'explication est là c'estàdire que le
Hamas ce n'est pas une
expression légitime des aspirations
légitimes du peuple palestinien c'est
une organisation islamiste radical
terroriste qui a qui a des intérêts qui
n'ont rien à voir avec les intérêts
nationaux du peuple palestinenne tel
qu'on peut le comprendre à Paris il il
est important de comprendre cela nous
sommes dans une dans une réalité
différente de celle que l'on a que l'on
imagine il me semble qu'il est important
de comprendre
aussi
que Israël dans son évolution radicale
l'autorité paltinenne dans son
autodestruction prolongée ont donné des
armes au ramas
oui moi je je je considère je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit je considère qu'il y a une
différence fondamentale entre le peuple
palestinien et l'organisation du ramas
et l'humiliation je suis d'accord avec
l'expression madame soudé l'humiliation
elle a été infligée au peuple
palestinien qui vraiment Jordanie ce
qu'il viv depuis des années n'est pas
satisfaisant mais ça n'a à mon avis rien
à voir avec les motivation
l'organisation les moyens mis en œuvre
par le ramas pour s'inscrire dans un jeu
géopolitique assez compliqué d'une
nature très différente même si
évidemment le les liens dialectiques
entre les deux choses sont évidents et
si bien que s'il y a non pas une
solution mais un chemin vers lequel nous
devons nous orienter c'est sur la
distinction entre les intérêts du peuple
palestinien et le le le sort du de
l'organisation ramas je pense que nous
avons trop longtemps les uns et les
autres et d'abord le gouvernement
israélien
ignorait les aspirations légitimes du
peuple palestinien et maintenant le
moment est venu vraiment d'essayer c'est
très compliqué d'y faire droit c'est en
tout cas ma ma ma conviction profonde
tout repose sur la distinction entre une
organisation terroriste qui n'est pas
fondamentalement représentative qui est
surtout dominatrice et dictatoriale et
un peuple palestinien qui lui a vraiment
été méprisé dans ses aspirations les
plus légitimes au cours des dernières
années voilà ce que je ressens
personnellement madame carois vous avez
vous êtes la dernière intervenante merci
merci monsieur le Président je je je
souhaite avant tout vous vous remercier
remercier nos intervenants mais vous
remerciz vous monsieur le Président
d'avoir organisé ce débat au sein de
notre commission 5 jours après as
l'effroid l'horreur absolue le temps de
l'émotion de pouvoir nous donner un
véritable espace de de débat je regrette
que certains commissaires ne puissent
être là malheureusement nous avons des
des des conflits d'agendas mais je pense
que tout le monde appréciera que que
vous ayez pris le temps de venir nous
éclairer aussi rapidement après ces
faits
terribles sur sur le sentiment
d'impuissance que nous pouvons éprouver
nous avons fait toute une analyse de ce
que nous aurions pu faire de ce que la
France n'a peut-être pas fait et aurait
dû faire aujourd'hui peut-être comme mot
de la fin que diriez-vous à la
représentation nationale sur ce que l'on
peut faire peut-être finir sur une note
d'espoir ou si ce n'est d'espoir
peut-être de d'action que que peut-on
faire dans les prochains dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochaines
dans les prochains mois si ce n'est au
plan international au moins au plan
national pour éviter que la société
française ne s'embrase et que ce conflit
ne ne soit finalement importé aussi dans
notre pays je vous
remerci moi qui vous remercie d'abord
c'est très très gentil de faire le de
faire d' des félicitations au président
de la commission il toujours très très
agréable de recevoir des compliments
même s'ils sont en l'occurrence pas très
justifiés car les seuls qui méritent
d'être remerciés ici sont nos trois
invités qui on on ont tout de suite
répondu présent à un appel qui leur a
été adressé très très récemment là hier
ou avant-hier et qui nous ont apporté
quand même des lumières absolument
considérables alors à la question
fondamentale que pose ééonor euh je
crois qu'il y a pas de réponse au-delà
de ce qui a été dit tout au long de
cette réunion je crois que nos trois
invités ont ont vraiment
euh dressé un constat très très précis
assez dur assez pénible euh ils ont
dégagé certaines orientations mais ils
nous ont aussi faire fait part de la
même perplexité que celle qui nous
habite sur la capacité que nous aurons à
que nous aurons à surmonter euh
rapidement et correctement ces
difficultés cela dit je veux pas parler
à leur place et avant de de les
remercier de prendre congé euh je tiens
à leors laisser euh euh la parole euh
pour l'ultime message qu'ils
estimeraient ne pas avoir encore
délivrés et dont il penseraiit que la
Commission ne peut pas continuer à vivre
sans l'avoir
entendu
Frédéric merci beaucoup je vais donc
sauver tout le monde parce que je pense
que sans mes mes propos à venir c'est
l'apocalypse non je je je quitte à
moitié ma casquette universitaire et je
prends pleinement celle du citoyen
français qui vient d'être dit de la
société française par par Madame et tout
à fait fondamental je suis de ceux qui
considèrent que le conflit
israëlo-palestinien ne doit pas être
importé en France tout le monde est
d'accord avec cela mais je seraai
extraordinairement sévère vis-à-vis de
ceux qui prétendus universitaires vrais
universitaires ou
considère qu'il faut malgré tout d'une
façon ou d'une autre l'importer et je
pense que on est là sur non seulement
une une entreprise ou une posture
irresponsable mais potentiellement
criminelle et je suis de ceux encore une
fois qui considèrent que on ne doit
absolument rien tolérer d'un point de
vue juridique moral politique pour s
sous prétexte de conflit
israëlo-palestinien dans notre
société je vous remercie C prop
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur vous voulez je
pense que vous avez certainement un
message que vous voudriez nous nous
délivrer cette fin de
réunion le même message obsessionnel que
j'essaie de faire passer tout au long de
notre
réunion je pars sur un sur un appel sur
un appel au secours si vous voulez et
tant pis si je dramatique je pars sur un
appel à l'action je pars sur un appel à
la à aider not peuple de sortir de lère
je sais que c'est possible et je vous
demande vraiment avec la Laura qui est
la vre
l'influence les capacités qui sont les
ves à vous faire l'interprète de cette
de ce sou de cette de cette imploration
auprès des responsabl
françaisopé merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
monsieur
juste d'un mot expliquer expliquer
expliquer avec clarté avec pédagogie
avec
modération faire comprendre que ce qui
se passe est d'une extraordinaire
importance et expliquer
pourquoi merci merci à vous trois je
crois tirer je crois qu'il faut tirer de
cette réunion nous en aurons d'autres
nous allons poursuivre ce ce débat cette
réflexion mais je crois que nous de vont
bien voir que trois trois sentiments
nous habitent et doivent nous habiter le
premier c'est effectivement
l'indignation et la compassion pour ce
qui arrive au peuple israélien et je
crois qu'ici tout le monde a ressenti
quel que soit les différentses analyses
politiques l'extrême souffrance du
peuple israélien et la légitime colère
qui est la sienne donc là je crois que
nos amis israéliens doivent être assurés
de notre profonde sympathie dans
l'épreuve qu'il a l'URE la deuxième
chose c'est ce que vient de dire c'est
ce que vient de dire Dominique moisi
comprend nous avons un devoir
d'intelligence un devoir de lucidité un
devoir d'explication moi j'ai toujours
été fasciné par la Une des une des
caractéristiques fondamentales du peuple
juif c'est de toujours comprendre au
cœur des drames les plus épouvantables
et qui lui arrive de comprendre pourquoi
comment et ce qu'il faut faire cette
prise de distance de l'intelligence
j'avais tout à fait observé ça quand je
travaillais avec Simon veille cette
prise de distance par rapport à l'orreur
quand elle parlait par exemple de ce qui
lui est arrivé à Auschwitz ou ailleurs
donc c cette capacité de maîtriser
l'horreur par l'intelligence c'est
quelque chose qui est un devoir pour
nous nous devons comprendre nous devons
expliquer nous devons analyser et puis
troisièmement et c'est un peu ce que
vous venez de dire Frédéric Anselme et
et et Ie Barnavi il y a une exigence de
volonté d'abord je crois que Frédéric a
raison nous devons veiller à ce que ce
qui s'est passé en Israël ne se traduise
pas par des violences des intolérances
des des des des déchirements et des
discordes à l'intérieur de la communauté
nationale française là nous avons tous
un voir dans nos partis politiques
différents pour vraiment amener les les
les les
nos concitoyens à à comprendre et à
réagir intelligemment et non pas
simplement à être tenté par la violence
et ça c'est notre rôle c'est ce que
j'essis j'ai essayé de faire en
organisant cette réunion commencer à
réfléchir on n pas fini hein c'est un
début commencer à réfléchir
apporter les éléments qui permettent de
traiter cette affaire avec la
civilisation qui doit nous caractériser
et puis deuxièmement j'ai été très
sensible enfin finalement j'ai été très
sensible à ce qu'a dit Ellie Barnavi sur
notre responsabilité politique
effectivement est-ce que la France a été
insuffisante ou pas je crois que
Dominique a eu raison de rappeler que le
le président de la République est resté
fidèle à l'inspiration fondamentale euh
de la de la France sur ce dossier est-ce
que nous en avons fait assez
certainement pas et si nous avons pas
fait assez c'est sans doute parce que
seul nous n'avons pas les moyens d'en
faire autant qu'il était nécessaire et
là l'appel à l'Europe est évident
l'appel de Monsieur Barnavi à un un
redressement par la conjonction des
peuples européens Dominique Boi s'est
associé à cette à à ce message en en
évoquant la nécessité d'une convergence
entre par exemple les Britanniques les
Allemands les Français les espagnols ou
d'autres euh je crois que là il y a
quelque chose de très important nous ne
pouvons pas être aux abonnés absents de
cette de de cette tragédie et les
Européens
vraiment
sencgass dans des querelles qui n'ont
qui ne sont pas pas dignes de qui ne
sont pas dignes de ce de des défis que
nous avons à relever ensemble c'est nous
parlons constamment du fait que nous
faisons un virage géopolitique et cetera
et cetera bah voilà le moment de faire
véritablement de la politique les
Américains ont mis un porte-avion
immédiatement je sais pas si c'est une
bonne une une bonne gesticulation ou pas
mais ça marquait qu'il voulait éviter un
embrasement régionale global nous
n'avons sans doute pas les moyens d'agir
de cette manière-là mais nous devons
être présents collectivement ensemble et
solidairement sur ce dossier ce sont les
trois leçons que personnellement je veux
pas imposer ça aux différents partis
politiques de cette commission chacun
est libre mais ce sont les trois les
trois messages que j'estime pour ma part
devoir être retenu de cette très très
intéressante c très intéressant échange
de vue que nous avons
eu solidarité et sympathie avec les
Israéliens conscience analyse capacité
d'analyse de compréhension et de
lucidité sur la situation qui est créée
par cette terrible affaire et
mobilisation de la volonté car nous ne
pouvons pas être aux abonnés ABS
de cette histoire merci cher Ellie
Barnavi merci cher Frédéric Ancel merci
cher Dominique moisi de nous avoir aidé
à comprendre le la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes et je crois que
nous repartons de cette réunion non pas
avec des idées complètement faites
fermées bouclé mais avec quand même
l'idée que il y a des exigences que
nouvelles que nous devons relever en
ensemble voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire et maintenant après avoir à nouveau
remercié nos trois invités je dis que la
séance est
levée